from exclusive items to portion sizes we
want to find all the differences between
KFC in the US and Italy this is food
Wars new season Italy new host want to
introduce you to a familiar food Insider
face
Claudia let's start with the original
recipe chicken if you're buying just the
original chicken you can get a two-piece
one is huge we also have lots of bucket
options but most of them combine the
original recipe wings and tenders if you
only want the original chicken the
largest size we have is a six piece
bucket looks a bit scin the other bucket
options include a variety of chicken
such as tenders and hot wings for
example if you want to feed two people
you can get the 10piece bucket this
contains four tenders and six crispy
tenders and if you want to feed four
people you can get this big boy here
this one is a 16 piece bucket and
contains four original recipe for $10
tenders for crispy tenders and for wings
this is actually the biggest thing on
the menu then in the US KFC's chicken
comes in four portion sizes you can
start off by getting a one piece alart
then a two-piece with a combo a three
piece with a combo and a four piece with
a combo all of which come with the side
of your choice a biscuit and a drink
then for the buckets we have an8 piece
the 12
piece o
and last but not least this luscious
bucket 16 pieces of chicken dinner is
served in America you can get those in
either original or crispy that makes our
biggest bucket 166% bigger than Italy
I've actually never really had KFC
before chicken is not so popular in
Italy like espe especially Fried Chicken
served like that so I'm really curious
to try it and
see yeah nice not a lot of spices it's
just like fried chicken which is what
what we promised let's see how one
chicken drumstick weighs compared to
Italy 64 G 97 G is anyone surprised that
the chicken in the United States is
bigger than every other country we've
done this food Wars with in Italy we
also have hot wings and they come in a
five piece and in a 18 piece bucket this
one is designed for three people
18 Wings in the US is definitely for one
person not three I could have six wings
and then have a full meal so they're
advertised as hot
wings I think to an Italian palot yeah
you could say these are spicy we also
got Wings here in the US now currently
at least the KFC I went to here in
Burbank has one size of wings the eight
piece and go ahead and take the bones
out crispy hey heat I can notice that
isn't overwhelming perfectly fine next
are the fries in Italy you can get three
sizes small medium and large in the US
we got two sizes of fries the individual
and the large let's weigh our biggest
size I never grow tired of that is this
the lowest we've gotten we've gone to
the same KFC every time apparently they
have fired that scooper because he or
she was being too generous in Italy KFC
offers drinks in two sizes a medium and
a large drinks in the US get two
fountain drink sizes the regular and the
large I will point out to you Claudia
and the rest of Italy that are regular
the smallest drink you can get at a KFC
is 591 ml which is much bigger than your
large but if you really want your thirst
quenched you get yourself the big
boy that is a half gallon 64 fluid
ounces or 1,000
92.7 M of Beverage let's measure the
large one to see if that's
true supposed to be 887 let me just even
get it up to 800 wo this is just 800 the
messes that this show forces me to
make if you are incredible at balancing
and you don't want to cap I guess this
is okay if you're just going to sit at
your table
like here's everything that you can get
a k in Italy that you won't find in the
US here's everything you'll find at a
KFC in the US you won't find in Italy we
have one exclusive chicken option you
can't get in Italy that is the extra
Krispy this is probably Clos to where
you get your original recipe and then
you got the extra crispy I mean
obviously it's it's night and day volume
up on this one this is
regular and of course the extra
crispy and if you're wondering yes way
better way more
flavorful we don't have extra crispy
chicken here in Italy but if you order
tenders you're going to get original and
crispy it does look much crispier it
also looks just looks much sad SW CU is
like literally flopping at least I can
see the chicken I can see some meat in
there this one is like completely hidden
in the butter like it could be anything
another exclusive are the KFC
nuggets you can get these in varieties
of 5 8 12 and 36 I went with the five
piece now Claudia take a good look at
this you and Italy have popcorn chicken
besides potential size differences I
really don't know what else is different
about these in Italy we don't have
nuggets but uh we have popcorn chicken
it we got the large but it comes also in
small and medium quietly sometime last
year KFC just took popcorn chicken off
the menu and I'm pretty bummed about
that I mean I like the Nuggets but the
popcorn chicken man it's just something
cuz they're a lot smaller and then the
chicken to skin ratio is more in favor
of the skin so you get a lot of that
savory skin in there rip popcorn chicken
you're very lucky Claudia you are very
lucky we were you guys like the guinea
pigs for this or are we the guinea pigs
for like a new recipe or
something I think I prefer a whole piece
like I think binging on like little bits
of chicken it's like so un Italian that
um I'm not sure that i' be getting used
to that snacking on little bits of fried
chicken while in a convenient tog go box
while driving a walking around is so
American and I love it I got to try this
this is what America's all about let's
move on to the chicken sandwiches in
Italy we have the Zinger this is
supposed to be Italy's version of the
spicy chicken that you guys have in the
US I don't know Joe how does that look
like similar yes Claudia your Zinger
sandwich look looks a little bit like
our spicy chicken sandwich here's ours
and we only have pickles on ours so no
lettuce and
tomato but after I took a bite you can
see there's like some red here so that's
supposed to be the spice there's like
the tiniest tiniest tiniest spice to be
honest then moving on we have this uh
tiny little thing the cranky crunchy or
cranky this one here is on the value
menu so it's more cheaper option and
then we got the colonel named after
colonal Sanders we don't really have
colonal here nothing we do but we keep
them for the Army I don't think theyve
ever opened a chicken restaurant then we
got the double Colonels does that mean
that another person joins then we have
the kentucki chicken and bacon I have to
say this is the biggest bacon that I've
seen in like Italian fast food chains
this to me feels quite quite thake and
you can also get this one in a double
and then we have the chicken grilled so
sauce sad sad lettuce hanging off Mayo
you can also get the double crispy which
is two chicken tenders in a bun here are
sandwiches you can get in the US you
can't get in Italy starting down here
the classic Chicken Little I don't know
it's just a tender in between two buns
here's what I would do I would go to KFC
I'd stand in line I'd order my meal and
get one of these and then demand they
give me this while I wait for the rest
of my food it's nothing it's nothing
it's like an appetizer and then of
course just the regular chicken sandwich
I have said on record several times that
I think KFC might have the best fast
food chicken sandwich in America there's
also apparently an ultimate barbecue
fried chicken sandwich that was new I
think it came and went as an Italian I'm
not so big on chicken burgers I think
the idea of having chicken in a burger
doesn't really resonate so well with us
it's like almost hurts my eyes there's
just too much Brown in it like I want to
see more color yeah that's absolutely
not the case here here as you can see
our chicken is deep fried and covered in
a mayoi sauce we're eating chicken all
the time in America yeah we eat a lot of
beef but we also eat a lot of chicken
and it is no way diet food here not at
all we also used to have Twisted wraps
here at KFC in Italy but sadly they're
not on the menu anymore they're still
worth mentioning though because of the
hilarious advertising uh campaign when
KFC launched them in Italy they actually
designed Italian leather handbags
supposed to hold your Twisters which is
a bit of a knockoff to like the fendy
baguette bag all right we might not have
Italian bags for our WS but we do have
KFC Crocs look how cool those look we do
have a couple wrap options you only get
them through the KFC application which
is not how I ordered anyway get the
classic one with a crispy tender there's
also a spicy one that I assume is
spicier and apparently you get two of
them for $5 which a pretty good deal but
I didn't get them here's a few hilarious
things things you can't get in Italy
over here is the famous bowl yes Claud I
know you're dying to know all about this
so I will tell you now it is nuggets
mashed potatoes gravy corn cheese
allinone convenient tub so this would be
I guess what's considered a
bites it's really heavy it's got to be
90% mashed potato it's a lot another
American exclusive is this a chicken pot
pie look at the size of this thing I
think this would just profoundly confuse
every Italian here's the thing about the
mashed potatoes and gravy you have to
get them together having them separately
seems very strange to me it is a classic
us side dish especially with things like
fried chicken apparently when Colonel
Sanders sold the business he compared
the mashed potatoes in a Manhattan store
to wallpaper paste topped with sludge
but that was back in the' 70s so
hopefully they've made some improvements
I'd say that they have I mean I know
like those those mashed potatoes look so
dry I understand you want to put some
some sort of liquid on them I just not
have any of it but for once the potatoes
don't look like radioactively yellow so
that should be a good sign we happen to
have some Italian style sides here on
the menu although I have no idea who
called this Italian stuff because no
Italian to me we have cheese puff to me
this look like like fried baby bells
that's the only cheese that I can think
of that have this
shape
I think it's some kind of
mozarella no okay yeah we have breads
just like funny funny bread it looks
very dry just but looking in it and then
we have corn on the cob the US has off
the cob this is like not Italian I've
never seen an Italian person have corn
the cob in Italy we also have four
salads but we were not able to get them
today those are a grilled chicken crispy
chicken an original chicken which we
don't know how that differs from the
crispy one and a veggie
salad right Claudia look at that look at
that mac and cheese it's American mac
and cheese I mean I don't really have
thoughts about mac and cheese because to
me that's just not Italian uh we just
sort of gave up on it and be like you
want it it's yours yeah I get it like
bright yellow but
Claudia what you can tell is how good
this
tastes other us sides you can get here
klaw Claud was talking about corn on the
cob we got corn off the cob AKA sweet
corn I'm just thinking in terms of the
American Experience I don't really be
all like doing this at my desk KFC for
lunch you I want to eat it and get going
so another thing we have here biscuits
and I feel like you get these with these
types of meals cuz it's good at sapping
up things like good at sapping up the
gravy on their own they're just
so I want to see if I can eat one like
without any liquid like how long it
takes me to eat a dry one ready this is
how dry these are ready timing
go I'm only halfway
through
hurt
time yeah not my favorite another
exclusive you can get here in the US is
a piece of alart chicken I feel like if
you went into a KFC in Italy it was like
I just want one drumstick they'd give it
to you I don't think they'd really push
back on it but our menu specifically has
you can get an individual piece of
chicken you get a drumstick a thigh or a
breast get chicken in this hand Famous
Bowl in this hand and walk right in the
traic sauce talk let's
go in Italy we have some exclusive
sauces starting from the original I know
you guys in the US have the cave sea
sauce does this look
similar I think if I were making sauces
I would have just continued you know
triing others after this
one yeah it's like a mayoi barbecue
ketchup and then we have the Smokey
barbecue sauce and then we have the
sweet imperial sauce that's a sweet and
sour
sauce very lemony but fresh yeah it's a
nice one I like this then move on to the
too hot for you jell
like it's not too hot for you it's just
too bad for me moving on we also have
garlic sauce I know you guys associate
Italy and Italian cuisine with garlic
please stop doing that we don't really
like it then we have a fresh pepper one
this one apparently contains
cheese tastes like no much to be honest
we also have creamy Curry finally we
couldn't get the only olive oil but we
do have olive oil and white vinegar and
olive olive oil and balsamic vinegar I
don't know if you want to consider olive
oil a sauce I have like mixed feeling
about it cuz that's definitely more
dressing are you curious to see how
chicken olive oil tastes like let's try
it olive oil and balsamic vinegar let's
see kind of brought it back to life a
little bit cuz he had cool down yeah I
should do this more often actually it
tastes less fried for some reason cuz I
always associate olive oil with like
grilled chicken so if you want to you
know trick your mind into thinking that
you're eating grilled chicken and not
fried maybe all you have to do is pour
some olive oil on it honey mustard honey
barbecue that's good buffalo ranch if
you are on aware we have a sauce here
that usually is on wings called the
buffalo sauce it's like a vinegary hot
sauce that is a a little north of
mild and the reason that Buffalo Ranch
is a thing is because when you eat
buffalo wings and they're spicy you dip
the wings in ranch a second sauce to
cool it down so we as Americans are used
to pairing buffalo sauce on the wings
with ranch dressing so they were like
let's just put it in one cuz God forbid
have two sauces but you want to have
just regular Ranch everyone on the
internet come at me all right Ranch is
just okay it all tastes the same also we
have a hot sauce a honey sauce we have a
lot of desert options here in Italy most
of them are just ice cream we start from
a plane ice cream cone then you can get
sanday they come plain caramel flavor
Nutella strawberry and chocolate and
then we have these the cream bowls they
come with Nutella flavor caramel
strawberry and chocolate they're kind of
similar to a sunde but they have that
this crunchy bottom and apparently the
caramel one is supposed to have lots of
layers this is the caramel one but I'm
not sure we can judge the number of
layers cuz it has absolutely melted so
we got a Nutella cream bowl and a
caramel one uh you know those like
backpacks for cats I think it's like the
same thing here curious about the
crunchy bottom oh yeah that is
crunchy actually reminds me a little bit
of you know the Ala the Cornetto it may
have another name in the US and they
have that crunchy bit at the bottom I
mean for us Italian Nutella is like dog
chocolate before chocolate always comes
Nutella just no questions asked it's
always been like this and before cream
as well uh the only exclusive dessert
option we have in America is this a
chocolate cake and it just occurred to
me I've actually never had this cake
let's see how we
did perfect cooked beautifully it's got
the right amount of Bounce isn't dried
out and now we taste
it exquisite you keep baking like that
you're going to win this competition I'm
I was started up as Gordon Ramsey every
impression I do of anyone is just kind
of that this actually pretty good yeah
they had those uh those those balls
that's those cream balls which is kind
of a weird thing to call it no I don't
want any of those I get it I like
dessert just as much as next guy but KFC
I want to load up on fried chicken I
want to load up on mac and cheese I want
to load up on mashed potatoes I want to
load up on corn if only someone could
put it all in one bowl for me dessert no
I want to eat eat fried chicken and tell
I'm about the burst and then I'm out so
the exclusive drinks in Italy are 7even
up lipon IC tea and beer found drinks
you can get in the US we do have a bunch
of exclusives I didn't get every single
one relax all right starting down here
sweet tea oh yeah their lemonade it's
really good it's addictive and our
lemonade is not carbonated it's still
Mountain Dew it's fantastic and the
reason I saved this one for last is
something you get exclusively at the KFC
in the us it is Mountain Dew sweet
lightning it's so good like you just
know it's like super sweet and super
chemically but I love it other drinks
you can get at a US KFC that we not get
was star and blackberry lemonade which
is currently
unavailable which country is getting a
better deal on its KFC let's compare a
few menu items to find out looking at
the chicken sandwich combo meal which
comes with a side and a medium drink
this whole thing in Los Angeles would
cost you
$10.99 note if you got each item
individually added up it would be
$12.76 in Italy you can also get a
similar meal that is called a Zinger
meal and that includes a sandwich a side
of choice and a drink this will cost you
€140 at the time of recording that is
equal to
$1.52 so that is 5% more expensive than
the US meal if you order these items
individually that will cost you €1
1360 and that's about1 15
$6 we also took a look at KFC's most
expensive items in Italy the most
expensive item on the menu is the 16
piece bucket this one cost
$42.90 which is about
$47 51 this is supposed to feed four
people for
$11.87 per person most expensive item on
the US menu is the 16 piece chicken meal
which includes 16 pieces of chicken
original or crispy four large size eight
biscuits and it cost you
$52.99 now this is meant to feed 7 to
eight people sure and it cost roughly
$662 per person which is 44% cheaper
than Italy's per person cost Italy KFC
puts a lot of efforts in this meals and
special offers so they can be better
value for money personally in Italy
we're not really used to having meals uh
we're very accustomed to just having a
big main course
that to me still feels a bit of an
American thing but uh this is American
food so I guess we're using their
customes as well if you're operating
under the assumption that this is for
seven people it's a pretty good deal but
you and I both
know this ain't for seven
people we want to see if there are any
similarities in the nutrition of KFC for
both countries now this is our chicken
sandwich and it has
650 calories if you'll notice there's a
lot of salt and fat in this sandwich
much over half your daily recommended
intake KFC Italy doesn't disclose their
calories on their website actually I
think disclosing nutritional information
like calories and everything I find that
quite an American thing that doesn't
mean it's like good or bad it's just
like we we don't really tend to count
calories in things every food Wars we've
done all the nutrition info all the
ingredients info in the US you can get
it no problem other countries they don't
provide
it let's take a look at are some
ingredients that KFC uses here in Italy
here are all the ingredients for the
fries nine is a lot potatoes and frying
oil how about two two ingredients and a
bit bit of salt and one chemical let's
just use one you know if we have two and
here are all the ingredients of the
fries in the
US 33 ingredients that's 24 more than
the ingredients in Italy's fries that's
nuts nine ingredients for this thing and
it doesn't even molded shade I would
expect it to be like perfect there's a
lot of flavors and colorings that be
used like paprika turmeric and aneto
extract color which is funny we put that
into the fries but we're making this KFC
also uses bleached white flour which
removes all the color so it seems kind
of counterproductive like they're taking
all the color out with the bleached
flour right and they're putting all
those chemicals back in to make them
look like fries I don't know why we do
that either so let's have a look at the
ingredients for a chicken drumstick
Italy chicken uses a lot of flavor an
aners gums and stabilizers for example
ganam gum and gu gum they are used in
meat products to keep the chicken tender
during the cooking process these gums
are also used for chicken that has a
butter around it so that when it's fried
it absorbs less oil as I said before
like Italians don't really look at like
ingredients like nutritional value
things and that is why I think there is
a lot of work done beforehand for us in
order to make the food as simple as
possible so that if you do look at the
ingredients you're not so shocked by it
and here are the ingredients of the
chicken in the US surprisingly smaller
than Italy's list although the US has
not noted what oil they use for frying
like Italy has so it would probably add
a few more ingredients now KFC actually
uses pressure frying instead of deep
frying like the other chains as it
allows for faster cooking time and
always keeps the meat moisture as less
steam evaporates let's take a closer
look at a few ingredients that some of
us may not rec recognize okay first up
sodium phosphate now helps stabilize the
pH of the food to keep them together but
is also popular over the counter
medicine for bow movements so don't be
surprised if Eden KFC makes you uh rush
to the bathroom next up mono sodium
glutamate flavor enhancer commonly add
to soups and processed Meats H we're
putting these names on screen right uh
this word looks like this and is
probably pronounce
dimyan
dioxane is antifoaming Agent derived
from silicone usually added to oils jams
and canned vegetables disodium
dihydrogen pyrophosphate this should be
a contest anyway okay prevents potatoes
in the fries from turning brown due to
oxidization which is natural for most
fruits and vegetables and just to add
that all these ingredients have been
approved by health professionals and
there are no safety concerns as long as
long as they're eaten in lower
quantities which in general is good
advice for eating fast food chickens in
the US are free of added hormones and
steroids however KFC does not disclose
much else about how the chicken is
prepared nor how much chicken is used
per item as of 2019 young Brands the
parent company of KFC stopped purchasing
chicken raised using antibiotics so I
guess they're heading in the right
direction KFC opened their first Outlet
in the 70s in Naples for some reason and
that that didn't work out and they
closed and then they came back to Italy
in 2014 the objective was to open 100
branches in four years they're not quite
there yet as of 2022 the stats say that
they've open 68 branches here in Italy
although it's been here since 2014 it
does still feel pretty new like Italians
are not so big on like chicken
especially grilled chicken it does still
feel like a very foreign idea KFC is so
popular in the US maybe the most popular
chicken chain Fried Chicken chain at
least I think it's like the Fried
Chicken chain to beat in the US there's
other chicken places that do chicken
sandwiches chicken burgers but as far as
like chicken on the bone I don't know
who's even competing with KFC I guess
it's Popeyes oh yeah Popeyes no I think
KFC is way more popular than than
popey's I say it's better if a KFC opens
in a new town for example in my hometown
he open last year there are huge lines
there are a lot of people that want to
try it because it's really the idea of
the American fast food chain that's
arriving so it's exciting it's different
again it's one of those things that I
think you do try it because of the hype
KFC adaptability is weird a couple years
ago it used to be a lot more stuff on
the menu and now is a lot less so their
adaptability is less about making stuff
that kind of caters to people's tastes
and more like no one's getting the wings
let's just do the Nuggets let's take all
this stuff off the menu let's pair it
down go go go for efficiency and
probably because it's cheaper to have
less ingredients so they've adapted to I
don't know um shifts in the market or
people's interest in KFC they really
don't deviate too far dish Wise from
like a fried chicken or a chicken in a
bun KFC is actually the chain that has
made the least effort to italianized the
menu I don't know actually weirdly I
think that for this it works because the
idea of eating fried chicken is so
foreign to us that I don't know how you
would how would you make that Italian
you maybe put some like fried coret
flowers with the chickens I don't know
you know for me to even think about a
similar Italian thing that weirdly I
think this may be working the way it is
so we'll see when they will reach 100
branches maybe sooner than we think from
calorie count to portion sizes we wanted
to find out all the differences between
McDonald's in the US and and Italy this
is food
Wars drinks at McDonald's in Italy come
in three sizes 250 ml 400 ml and 500 mL
we're now going to measure a 500 mL Coke
to see if that's true oh oh I think
we're surpassing that it's like just
right below the 600 Mark but almost
there so quite generous drinks in the US
also come in four sizes the the extra
small which is 355 ml or 12 O the small
474 ml or 16 flu ounces ahe the medium
621 ml or 21 flu ounces and the large
946 ml or 32 flu ounces since we were
the ones that filled this up at the uh
restaurant and I don't think we got it
all full up I'm going to go ahead and
fill this what I think is reasonable I
can't do to the top cuz the cap is
recessed okay 32 surely you just right
there's the 32 line not even close it's
closer to 24 than it is 32 so fries in
Italy come in three sizes the regular
which technically the small medium and
large here in America our fries come in
four sizes the kids which comes in the
Happy Meal look at this little guy a
little guy the small the medium and the
large all the food Wars heads watching
know that in the China episode our large
McDonald's fry was 175 gram and then
Japan episode our large McDonald's fry
was 190 G so clearly there's some
difference in grammage depending on I
don't know the McDonald's will go to the
scooper who knows so we're going to
weigh our large right now ready
fantastic now let's go 185 not a bad
scoop we got a good scooper this time
seems pretty small actually what about
MEC nuggets in Italy you can get a bag
of four a box of six pieces nine pieces
and 20 pieces Claudia in the US our
McNuggets are available in these sizes
the four piece the six piece 10 piece 20
piece which you also have but we go up
one more here in America our largest
size the 40 piece now if my calculations
are correct this is double your largest
size the iconic Big Mac both countries
have it but we're going to compare ours
to italies by weighing it 226 G for us
Big Mac and here is an Italian Big Mac
or E Big Mac as is written here and
we're going to weigh it now 209
G here are all the items on the
McDonald's Italy menu that you won't
find in the US and here are all the
Donald's menu items from the US you
won't find in Italy get a good look
Claudia let's start from the burgers we
have a bunch of Italian burgers that you
won't get in the US the first one we got
here is a chicken Big Mac oh right just
destroyed chicken Big Mac is that being
inverted is that supposed to look like
this the cheese helps a little bit sauce
is as well moving on we have a bacon Big
Mac yeah so there's two strips of bacon
but they're not quite big so it does
look like maybe it's just one that's
been cut in half we got a crispy MEC
bacon which is like cheeseburger double
Patty and some bacon again a bit on the
side it's funny actually because you
know growing up I thought that the
crispy bacon was the the iconic
McDonald's item and it's weird that it
is actually an Italian exclusive here
are all the burgers in the US that you
can't get in Italy starting down here
the quarter pound of with cheese it
really is just a cheeseburger that is a/
qu pound of meats it's a great go-to
burger meat cheese onions pickles
ketchup and mustard and if you want more
meat you get the Double Quarter Pounder
correct not the half pounder the Double
Quarter Pounder with cheese two patties
more meat more
cheese it's a fantastic sandwich and
then we've got the first one of the my
selection range which is a range that
was um designed with Joe Bastianich he's
an American like TV personality and Chef
this one is spec and Asiago so yeah very
traditional spec is a type of cured meat
it's like a smoked ham yeah it's a
smoked ham from the north of Italy it's
actually very very nice just very salty
with that smokey flavor it's one of my
favorite and then we have aago which is
a cheese made pretty much in the same
area there's also mayo and zucchini in
there a bit dry I think you do taste the
cold cut the spec just brings that
saltiness smokiness very nice and the
cheese also is quite good yeah actually
I don't know if you've noticed but it is
much bigger than the others I mean we
can even take like a bacon Big Mac even
though it's supposed to have two paties
it is much bigger and then we have
another myel ction Burger this one is
called my BBQ this one has got barbecue
sauce yes I can see it gooda cheese and
bacon and uh it's all topped off with
some balsamic vinegar it does still have
the same sort of fancy Patty that we had
before right and after this very nice
and fancy um Burgers we have a
glutenfree
burger oh wait wait why is it coming a
bag
o yeah very ooh yeah not excited about
this just I don't like the bread uh I'm
sure you can find better gluten-free
bread there are so many around and if
you want vegetables on your burger for
some strange reason you can get the quar
pound of a cheese
deluxe with lettuce and tomato and
Mayo like a pock got a mayonnaise on
that one that's kind of weird ah it
tastes great he just want to go all in
on the meat you get a Double Quarter
Pounder with bacon look at
this
right it's really good I Al to said and
surprise another thing in our menu you
guys don't have the McDouble McDonald's
has a double cheeseburger which is
double the meat double the cheese but
also there's a McDouble on the menu
what's the difference you ask well
McDouble only has one slice of cheese as
you can see see from here on top you got
ketchup mustard and uh pickles no cheese
but the cheese is in between here get at
times are tough in economy but get the
extra slice of cheese guys come on I
mean we're not robots here we got to
have some pleasure in our lives and I
think you should get that extra slice of
cheese absorb the cost of it it's
perfectly fine you're doing great come
on next one is another one of those my
selection it's uh chicken avocado and
bacon Burger H it's got a different bun
this one oh fancy all right yeah avocado
is there there's like cabbage bit ex
excited about that and this one has
kacho cavalo cilano cheese I don't know
we can call this you know sa T the
cheese
t kacha cavalo comes from the same
family of mozzarella they're called
pasta filata cheeses and it's just
basically the way that you make cheese
uh when you split the milk into curs and
way it's made in a different way and you
could say that kacho cavalo is like a
Ned mozzarella so it's a very versatile
cheese that I think is not very well
known abroad So yeah thank you
McDonald's for making that uh a thing on
your menu so everybody can know about it
so here's the cheese that we were
talking about it's just almost a shame
it's been put there with like avocado
and this cabbage next on we've got
double chicken barbecue after seeing all
these big ones they do look quite small
and then we have a chicken burger this
one is different from a Mech chicken
because it has ciss uh sauce and no lece
I think this is glue it looks like
there's a type of glue that looks
exactly like that we also thought it'd
be fun to compare Happy Meals here's the
US One open up this box take a look
around I'm pretty sure this is Pokémon
this one comes with kid fries nuggets
which we got a six piece and our Pokemon
toy they get the six piece it's funny
like a six piece still seems kind of
like a lot for a kid Pokemon themed toys
coming at you these days what is this uh
okay so we got um Pikachu does this have
any value cuz there's like rare ones
like there's ones that have a lot of
value to them but any not the ones inest
ones right
card any
value we got
tanos
yeah and of
course
sandaconda I'll go look on uh eBay after
this and see if uh these are worth
anything culturally I have no idea what
this is I don't know what this is a
thing no I have no idea
who I don't I don't remember any of
those
names
uh cha
Charzard cyard is this
cyard
charmar okay in a Happy Meal in Italy
you can find four items obviously there
is a drink uh then there is a main
course that could be either nuggets and
a hamburger and exclusive to Italy is a
chicken burger and a Mac toast which is
what we got today we're going to see
that in a moment then there is a side it
can either be fries or baby carrots and
a dessert this can be um either fresh
fruit actimel which is technically a
drink but it's a dessert here and
Parmesan here's our
mcto nice the surprise um of the day
yeah they're just doing some Hot Wheels
collaboration so let's have a look at
what is it I don't know do you think I
can find a Vine here oh cute little
skateboard pink
one we also have one exclusive WRA
option here in Italy it's a Mac Wrap
with crispy chicken breast and Parmesan
or Parmesan orano it's made in
collaboration with jalo zafferano which
is um the number one recipe website in
Italy to be honest I think they could
have come up with a better
recipe maybe for the wrap the wrap does
look very sad just the actual bread
chicken looks okay Italy clearly has
plenty of exclusive chicken sandwich
options but we have a few of our own
here namely the MC Krispy and the spicy
MC Krispy and a deluxe version of each
sandwich let's take a look it looks
closer to a chicken sandwich you would
find at a chick-fil-et and then now uh
Burger King has the Chicken King I think
McDonald's did all the research that
they do to release this the mccrispy
sandwich now as you can tell it's just
pickles on here a crispier more natural
looking piece of fried chicken
and no sauce does always have no
sauce I don't like that I don't like a
place that gives you food in like
assembly
requirements for the most part I just
get the sandwich the way it's supposed
to be so this put your own sauce in it
it's like no you put it on here's the
deluxe of it it yay that has mayo whoa
this to me is like yeah do this every
time this should just be the sandwich I
don't if you're like me and you want to
spice it
up they have the spicy oh come on they
were their spicy sauce on here somewhere
then of course they got the spicy deluxe
which of course has spicy sauce and all
veggies in there so yeah McDonald's
still a contender in the chicken
sandwich game I feel now we're on to the
exclusive sides here in Italy the first
one that we got is is cheesy fries the
same fry just with a bit more bacon we
go here yeah cheddar and bacon this is
like I don't know a very sad Italian
take on poutin on the menu next for
sides we've got pancerote
so actually very excited about these
because ooh they are a pancerote are
from my hometown body in the south of
Italy the main difference is that
usually pancerote like the traditional
ones they are this big they're like
usually pretty wide it's like a main
meal Panero normally they have tomatoes
and mozzarella is the most common
filling but uh in body uh again where
they are from uh you can get them with
ground beef mozzarella and cooked ham
these are actually my favorite I used to
go and get them after school um you know
that's just they are the perfect
snack quite good actually filling is
okay but I think a r pancer when you
bite into it basically all the fillings
should almost come out it should like
pop you know like the first reaction
when you eat a paner this is like and
then you sort of put your hand here and
just avoid a complete mess this brings
us to the next snack which is parano
reano or parmesan this is one of the
most counterfeit cheeses in the world so
in Italy but also in Europe because of
this whole protection thing anything
that's called even parmesan not the real
name parmo reano is in fact the real
thing so at least we're safe on that
side having said that I think um most of
the parmesan parmo that you will
find around you know in Supermarket it's
like been aged for the bare minimum
which is 12 months so it is good it is
the real Fame but if you can choose just
have something that's been aged for a
bit longer I think in Italy we do eat a
lot of cheeses snack like as it is and I
do have um definitely memories of like
me coming back from school you know and
then just in the afternoon grabbing some
cheese off the fridge and like having a
couple of slices or even more than that
um I think my mom still does that so
sorry for exposing you
Mom love it over here we got another
exclusive there are actually three
salads on the menu uh one is just a
plain salad one is a salad with um
tomatoes and then we got one with crispy
chicken breast and Parmesan we could
also select a dressing and we added
olive oil um you could also get a tiny
bottle of balsamic vinegar or just
vinegar we actually have no exclusive
sides in the US every side option in our
menu can also be found in Italy I will
say though I love that they have a stick
of cheese as a side kind of like a
pallet cleanser I would love that I
would love to snack on cheese I love
snacking on cheese we should have more
cheese is what I'm trying to say we
could bring it back with the sauces it's
time for sauce talk Italy Edition L
sauce
talk that had to offend somebody sauce
talk we have several exclusive sauces
here in the United States including
spicy buffalo and then we have Ranch
honey mustard sweet and sour now I have
two because one is from the movie Loki
apparent L and of course you just get
honey uh all these that probably go
sweet and
sour but barbecue which they do have is
my favorite we have one exclusive sauce
in Italy which is spicy mustard sauce
yeah yeah it is a bit spicy not so much
though doesn't numb your tongue I think
actually it has a sweet aftertaste for
some reason for the early risers there
are plenty of exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's and they're all
Savory now first thing I'm want to talk
about are the biscuits I'm not the
person to describe American biscuits to
the rest of the world they should have
hired a poet this is the bacon egg and
cheese biscuit but you can get a biscuit
version of any meat or cheese
combination that you want in the middle
here though Italy Claudia everyone look
at what I'm about to show you you know
what pancakes are you know syrup is you
obviously know what breakfast sandwiches
are this right here is a McGriddle and
they replace the buns with this these
bun pancakes this is a pancake Italy a
pancake these here and they somehow
injected syrup in them so it's not like
syrup like a sauce it's just like
already syrup somehow and it is Savory
and sweet at the same time it is so
delicious it's a McGriddle it's
fantastic I love these this is a bacon
egg and cheese McGriddle but once again
you can get it in any various sausage
egg Andor cheese combination that you
want MC griddles check them out I am the
McGriddle number one fan over here in
the OG breakfast sandwich this is the
Egg McMuffin they got the big breakfast
with or without Hot Cakes I went with
hot cakes you got eggs bacon pancakes
English muffin this thing's fantastic
and if you want to just get hot cakes
and sausage you can also do that and
each order of Pancakes comes with our
hot cakes syrup I think an unsung hero
of the McDonald's breakfast menu been a
fan of this for years it is the sausage
breakfast burrito now let's be honest
Italy in case you're wondering this in
no way represents an actual burrito I
want to make that perfectly clear I
would not put this in the same category
as any sort of burrito breakfast or
other otherwise but it's its own thing
and I think it is
fantastic it is in a flower
tortilla scrabbled eggs sausage yes I
know Peppers
cheese and the secret
weapon is this their Mexican style salsa
again there is
nothing authentically Mexican about this
but it tastes great this was a go-to for
years I could put away about four of
these uh McDonald's also does offer
oatmeal specifically fruit and maple
oatmeal moving on the Italian McDonald's
also sells breakfast items we've
got that's super sad we got scrambled
eggs with bacon and a muffin and bread
which what does look more like a muffin
and then we have a Mech muffin with
bacon and egg yeah Italians don't really
have Savory breakfast
it's definitely um a habit like you just
associate breakfast with sweet items all
right the US also has their own
exclusive maafe
items where' they
go the McDonald's is near our studio did
not have the maafe food
[Music]
items McDonald's in Italy has really
made an effort with the me cafe uh menu
items and there are really a lot of
items on the menu here so let's start
from the croissants we' got quite a few
on the menu I think this one here uh
because you can see a little bit of
brown this is the cocoa one with
sourdough pretty safe to eat this is the
plain one does look more like a French
star Cel nice
layers in there as well some air over
here it's quite hard to tell but there
is a subtle sub layer of jam this is
berries and cereal so the dough it looks
it's a little bit stiffer
and yeah does smell a little
bit more like cereals same amount of jam
that as in the others not not very
generous actually I think this one is
the last one that we got so is the
custard this looks
like we have a bit more in there
obviously it's hard to tell because the
custard is the same color as the um as
the dough has kind of turned the dough
Yellow Nice lots of lemon in there
another pastry option that you can get
is this cream braid uh this is quite a
typical thing as well in Italy like you
do get this kind of pastries you can get
them also Savory in like different
regions of Italy let's see if they were
generous with the cream
here yeah I'll say
so I prefer this cream in Italy you can
also get uh some cakes we have
tiramisu which is yeah a traditional
Italian thing but not a breakfast item
like I wouldn't really have breakfast
with tiramisu I know you guys want to
hear the opinion of an Italian so we
going to try this tiami Su and see if
it's
proper yeah it's quite good actually we
do have other Cakes as well we have this
one which is Tora de Lona in Italian um
and that literally translates to
Grandma's cake in English this one has
lemon custard and pine
nuts I think it's a bit of a joke that
this is actually called Grandma's cake
just because you know every Italian
grandma that's good in the kitchen will
be able to make make something like a
100 times better than this we've got a
strawberry cheesecake let's move on to
this three layer chocolate cake it's
like an absolute
Beast it's a bit too much I wouldn't
have this for breakfast like and then we
have a few more items here at the me
cafe in Italy we have a marshmallow
dut which looks like the most artificial
thing ever seen then we've got a Nutella
muffin it is true that Italians love
Nutella and they eat it all the time you
know again when I was a child my parents
used to hide
it sad and the last item that we've got
is uh macaroons we have chocolate
macaroons raspberry macaroons and
pistachos macaroons or pisto as we do
say
here
oh the inside is like dangerously green
they don't taste so much like pistachio
to be honest desserts McDonald's us we
have these exclusives turn down here the
baked apple pie the day they stopped
frying these is the day I stopped eating
them now they pulling this with like
trying to make it look like it's a
homemade pastry it's not this this was
the spit out of an AI oven
[Music]
machine one a second no human I'm the
first human hand to touch this also
chocolate chip cookies they come in
orders of 1 three the trilogy or a tote
of 13 one good thing about the
McDonald's we went to today is the
McFlurry machine was totally working and
I got this one the M&M's McFlurry we use
the mini M&M's which are better than
regular M&M's I don't know why they just
are Sundays Sundays Sundays maybe my
favorite as a kid the caramel
Sunday m oh that's my childhood right
there and get a fudge one as well for
Italian exclusive desserts we have uh
pistachos MEC flurry then a Bachi
perugina mecf flurry Bachi perugina are
very popular uh chocolates they are made
in peruja which is in the center of
Italy a town in the center and here we
have a coffee sunde it's quite nice that
I they actually gave us the espresso so
that we can make our own a bit like an
aato in a way the other SU are caramel
berries another Bachi perugina again and
fatte which is basically the Italian
version of
vanilla
o nice yeah now on to the cold drink
options uh starting down here all the
soda options you get here in the US of
course we have way more than Italy
starting with Dr Pepper oh come
here so fantastic Diet Coke no
this completely unnatural looking thing
is highy orange lava blast it's not
carbonated but it's also not juice I
can't explain it it's high se you can
also get a sweet tea and an unsweetened
iced tea at McDonald's what I did feel
like getting was this the Frozen Fanta
blue
raspberry oh God it's so sweet and so
serpy don't drink this don't give it to
children children don't have it ever
they also have a Coke version frozen
Coke also don't bother lemonade though
so we found out that lemonade in America
is the least different from Lemonade in
the UK again this is not carbonated it's
not really juice it's something
different I don't know what lemonade is
like in Italy
but oh man so tart and so good on to
coffee drinks or should I say cold
coffee drinks from here to here
understand there's not a thing in Italy
which I think is hilarious
this giant glass right here is iced
coffee you can also get it caramel
flavored or french vanilla flavored I
went with black the Ace of Spades right
here oh man they do something with their
coffee there they do something where it
tastes like it's really roasted I mean
I'm sure it's not you also get a ice
latte but this over here is a frappe you
can get a mocha frappe or a caramel
frappe basically if you're an adult and
you want a milkshake you get a Frapp you
we also get smoothies at McDonald's we
have a mango pineapple smoothie and a
strawberry banana smoothie in Italy we
have a few exclusive drinks let's start
with the cold options we have lip and
ice tea both in lemon and Peach then we
have some fruit juices we have PE AE
which is very popular here in Italy um
it's should be very orange is a mix of
orange carrots and lemon yeah very
orange and it's named AER which is a c e
after the three vitamins that these
fruits or like vegetables I guess the
carrots contains and then we got peach
fruit juice and here are our McDonald's
hot coffee drinks coffee right Italy all
right we get it we went a little
overboard with our coffee drinks here in
America and McDonald's of course is no
different you can get a caramel
macchiato a caramel
cappuccino why are we doing so much
caramel stuff in America right ah
caramel latte you can also get it in
vanilla don't you can also get a mocha
latte we have a uh premium roast coffee
as I said before I don't know what
they're doing in McDonald's
but I like the coffee but you can also
get finally a black hot tea what is this
the
UK the hot drinks exclusive to Italy are
are obviously the king of hot drinks
espresso uh then we've got a Moroccan
coffee which is not Moroccan in the
sense of it's not Moroccan style coffee
uh but weirdly enough and to be honest I
never really understood this it's named
after a type of Moroccan leather that
looks this color honestly it's like an
espresso with some milk and then we got
ginen coffee and barley coffee we
technically shouldn't really be cold
coffee because it contains no coffee it
has just barley and this is like an
alternative for people that cannot drink
coffee and uh they still want to have
something like a little espresso after
lunch yeah it smells very
cereally I don't know I'm not be fun and
then we got just a standard uh latte
macato this is like the closest thing
you would get to a latte that you will
find here in Italy so it's just a lot of
milk with a bit of coffee and some foam
at a
top in Italy a Big Mac will cost you €6
and 10 in dollars that's about
$676 a Big Mac in the US will cost you
$629 it's a 3% price increase from Italy
to the US what if you turn that into a
combo meal in Italy a small Big Mac meal
with medium fries and a medium drink
will cost you 8
890 and that's
$986 does a combo meal make a difference
in the US a medium Big Mac combo meal
over here will cost you
$142 you can also save some money if you
buy in bulk here in Italy you can get a
2 person Mac menu which includes two Big
Macs two large portions of fries two
large uh coca-colas six nuggets for
€8 in the US we only do Big Mac combo
meals as mentioned before so in order to
get the same order in Italy you would
have to order two Big Mac Meals plus six
nuggets on the side it would cost around
$36 which in Italy is about
€33 pricewise I think they are
definitely better value than other fast
food chains well not to believe Five
Guys I know that one is has a reputation
for being quite expensive but I think
the burger is like half the price for
the Panera I think that was more than 3€
3 something which honestly for like
three of those as as side it is a little
bit sad but again I grew up in the town
of panarotti and um I used to have like
a full one this size for
like2 that was 15 years ago so maybe now
it would translate into something like
maybe five or six Once Upon a Time
McDonald's was the cheaper option it was
a lot of food for not a lot of money as
many people probably pointed out on
social media this food is no longer
inexpensive it's not
expensive maybe because of the
competition maybe because of inflation
probably because of corporate greed
McDonald's and most fast food I find is
not a good value
anymore let's compare some items to see
what the nutrition is of McDonald's food
a sandwich that exists in both countries
and is theoretically identical is the
Big Mac in the US a Big Mac contains 590
calories 34 G of total fat 46 G of carbs
and 9 g of sugar how about an Italian
Big Mac one of those here contains 509
calories um of these there are 26 G of
total fat 42 G of carbs of which 90 G
are sugars and then there are 920 mg of
sodium what if we made it a combo meal
starting with the fries am medium fry in
the US contains 320 calories 15 G of
total fat 43 G of carbs no sugar and 260
mg of sodium while a medium fries in
Italy contains 330 calories 16 G of
total fat 41 G of carbs of which 0.4 G
are sugars and 212 mg of sodium and
let's add the medium Coke to the mix it
contains 210 calories no fat 56 carbs 56
of those are sugar and 55 Mig of sodium
that's funny there's salt in the soda
we'll do the same here here's what's
inside a medium Coke in Italy it's 168
calories 0 g of fat 42 G of carbs 42 g
of sugar so it's like all sugar and 0 g
of sodium that leaves the total for the
Italian meal at this 1,07 calories 42 G
of fat 125 G of carbs 51.4 G of sugars
and
1,32 mg of sodium while in the us the
total ends up looking like
this let's talk about ingredients now
McDonald's Italy shares a lot of
information actually about its
ingredients uh that's because the
majority of the items on the menu are
made with 100% uh Italian products the
beef like the one that's used in the Big
Mac is so SCE from over 15,000 different
Farms are located in Northern Italy
around the regions of Lombardy uh where
we are now in uh the capital of which is
Milan and pedmont there are apples from
South tro which is where spec is made
just to the border with Austria and just
to give some recognition to the southern
regions because I'm from there uh so no
bias at all we've got some apricots from
the um vuan National Park so in Campania
and CIA and oranges and when we talk
about dop this red label here is what
you're looking for it's a label that's
used for a lot of traditional products
around the EU and that means that they
have to be made with certain following
certain specific standards most of the
time in a very artisanal way but that
also means that certain products like
parmesan cannnot be made outside of a
specific area that has to do with the
climate so for example for cheese the
main argument is that it's a raw milk
cheese and in raw milk cheeses you do
taste what the cows eat so obviously the
grass has a different taste depending on
where you are in the world but we do
have some American sourced ingredients
for McDonald's the potatoes used for our
fries are grown in Washington at 100
circles Farm which is owned by Bill
Gates apparently they grow the potatoes
in circle so big you can see it from
space the potatoes are then cut into
fries at 70 mph which is faster than a
cheetah that's the unit of
measurement that natural secret
ingredient to McDonald's fries is beef
flavoring which they've been doing since
the 1950s want to see there's any
differences in the US and the Italy's
Big Mac these are all the ingredients in
a big Mech in the us all together that's
68 ingredients to make up a big Mech
that's a lot 28 of those ingredients are
in the bun which is quite a lot for
bread the Big Mac sauce also has a lot
of ingredients 26 alog together and it
seem like we added a lot of relish to
ours which bulks out the ingredients in
Italy there are 54 ingredients in a Big
Mac here they
are we only have 20 ingredients in the
band actually because we don't fortify
the flour like you do in the US Our Big
Mac sauce has 15 ingredients which is
still nine less than the uh us Big Mac
Joe most of the other ingredients are
similar but we don't have as many
colorings or thickers as you do in the
US us some of the ingredients listed in
our Us big Mech sauce caught our
attention so we want to explain what
they are first up propylene glycol
alginate is derived from brown seaweed
and is a thickener used in foods to give
it smooth natural texture next up we got
hydrolized corn which is a plant protein
from corn or Maze and is used as a
flavoring for its Umami taste sodium
citrate helps cheese to melt without
becoming
greasy I did grow up uh with with
McDonald's I definitely celebrated a
couple of birthdays over there I had my
uh share of like happy meals with like
lots of little girly toys it is
definitely considered healthier than
other fast food chains because he has
been around for quite some time but also
obviously because he has italianized a
lot over the years incorporating things
like parmesan or like traditional
cheeses and cold cats so just appealing
a little bit more to the taste T of like
Italians I have been to stores in the US
and the UK um and Italian McDonald's
seem I don't know a little bit fancier
it's everywhere it made burgers and
fries and sodas to go the most popular
meal in the country and then how many
places followed suit with Burger King
and Wendy's and all the like and now we
got chicken sandwich versions on you a
fried chick
McDonald's McDonald's ified the entire
country and the world McDonald's is like
Nike or Christianity it's
everywhere from calor count to portion
sizes we wanted to find out all the
differences between Burger King in Italy
and the US this is food
Wars in Italy our drinks come in three
sizes small medium and large we're going
to measure the large one to see how much
it actually contains that's supposed to
be 500 mL I think we're getting close to
600 actually 140 ml extra Burger King in
the US our Fountain drinks come in four
sizes value small medium and large and
the large is 38 fluid oun or
1,120 ML and now I would like to measure
the largest and see if that's exactly
how much they gave
us it's almost exactly 32 fluid ounces
it's not close to 38 o yeah it says 38
in the bottom here hey someone who works
at Burger King or someone who works in
fast food why why why do they say here's
how big the cup is and then clearly it's
not that amount what am I missing here
every single place does it here in Italy
we have three sizes of fries small
medium and large Burger King in the US
they got four fries sizes over here's a
value then the small the medium and the
large so I I know that in food War
history Burger King is actually lied to
us so let's see if they've been honest
with me today in Italy and measure every
single one of them the sizes are working
now the small it actually smaller than
the medium I have no proof of this I
think they saw our Us versus UK Burger
King episode saw us them call out # fry
gate 2021 when fr20 and uh they're
running scared but they
still trying to pull it over a US
Whopper the Whopper is a fantastic
sandwich
on to the nuggets in Italy they come in
three sizes a six- piece nine piece and
20 piece in the US our nuggets come in
three sizes uh two if you go into the
restaurant apparently you get the four
piece or the eight piece but also on
Uber Eats an exclusive apparently you
get a 16 piece both Italy and the US
serve onion rings in Italy they come in
E piece 12 piece
and 16
piece so we have four onion ring sizes
and I want to point out that for us we
just do it by cup size we're not doing
it by number of onion rings like they do
in Italy I have to say they were very
generous of the onion rings at ours I
mean this is the value this thing is
overflowing with onion rings the small
medium and
large here's everything that you can
find at Burger King in Italy that you
won't find in in the US and here's
everything you can find in the menu at a
US Burger King you can't get in Italy
let's start with the burgers in Italy we
have the Italian King collection which
comprises these two burgers here the
first one is the paraham and scamorza
burger scamorza is a cheese from South
Italy where I'm from so scorta it's a
bit like a mozzarella in a way like they
come from the same family of cheeses uh
they're made in a similar way but scorta
it's like aged for like a week like not
so much so it's like a hard mozzarella
let's see how it tastes in a
burger
nice not a fun of the onions I think
they overpower a little bit the taste of
the cheese without maybe the Patty it
does seem like a traditional Italian
sandwich and then we have the parmesan
Burger this one has bacon in it appar
when Burger King launched this burger
they had to buy something like 500
wheels of Parmesan Jano which is like
parmesan in Italy they are the same
thing um so quite a lot of Wheels um I
don't know it feels like a dream to be
in one of those rooms with like 500
wheels of
parmeson it feels like I don't know next
time you do it please call me Burger
King I'm coming to collect the
cheese better this one than the other
one this one is a little bit less messy
the flavors come out individually I can
taste everything yeah I like this one
always on the parmesan team and then we
got the Big King this is supposed to be
Burger King's uh version of The Big Mac
this one uh it's slightly different to
the US uh because it has an extra bun in
the middle and apparently has Special
Sauce that's supposed to taste like
Thousand Island sauce very yellowy I
never had Thousand Island sauce I don't
think I've ever seen it even in a
supermarket this is a bit vinegary like
a bit like tartar sauce in a way
but I don't know I'm not a fan but I
don't know maybe that's just like the
aftertaste of pickles that's also
something I don't like I know Joe
doesn't like them so yeah there's two of
us yes Claudia just likes pickles too
I'm so happy to hear that Claudia has
impeccable taste so for her to dislike
pickles must mean that I also have
impeccable taste so me and Claudia no
pickle friends and then we've got the
bacon Burger King 3.0 it's got three of
everything it's got three patties three
cheeses and actually eight strips of
bacon it's so heavy I mean I'm going to
take this to the gym to use as like a
proper weight it just looks gross it
looks like I don't know like cemon I
don't know how this is an exclusive to
Italy I feel like if I want to indulge
I'll just have two of something else
that's a little bit less messy there are
eight strips of bacon though and
apparently they are different in Italy
than in the US so let's have a look and
then we've got the Bronx steak house if
you are from the Bronx does this look
familiar to you and then we have the uh
veggie
Steakhouse same thing just with a veggie
PTY what is this it's like veggie bacon
the first time I see it why is it
brown it looks like a
candy
tastes like salt and like frying oil not
so much like
bacon yeah does give you the feeling of
like just having a regular burger this
is not technically vegetarian because
it's cooked on the same Grill as the
meat Patty I guess this is a burger for
people that eat meat that want to try a
veggie option the veggie Steakhouse that
might be a translation error I don't
know if it could be a veggie and a
steakhouse then we've got the big king
XXL so bigger size than this one uh this
one has got two patties four cheeses and
Special Sauce bigger onions as well then
we have the plant-based Whopper and then
we've got the crazy Cheese Whopper this
one is a delivery exclusive apparently
for the cheese lovers to be honest as a
cheese lover what is this amount of
cheese just it's ridiculous there was
more in any other any other Burger is
just for the lovers of like weirdly
hanging strips of bacon maybe all right
us Burger exclusive options starting
right here got the bacon cheeseburger
look how small this is by the way but as
you can see Burger got bacon and cheese
believe it moving on to the impossible
Whopper I think that's this one with the
lettuce yep impossible is a brand of
plant-based meat here in the United
States that is just that made from
plants animals were harmed in the making
of this burger I think something that
should be noted there is disclaimer on
the Burger King website that says our
impossible meat is cooked in the same
Broiler as the regular meat and also the
mail on these Burgers does have eggs in
it so uh good effort Texas Double
Whopper come on Texas Texas is a state
in the United States that does
everything bigger so of course they have
their own Whopper it's a Double Whopper
double the size of regular Whopper look
at this got double the meat see that and
jalapenos on here although they're kind
of not existent but they're on there in
the US we have the single qu pound King
you saw that earlier I absolutely
destroyed it I threw it away but also we
have a single impossible King same thing
as the impossible Whopper why am I
talking like this uh look at that I mean
you could put this melted cheese on a
piece of shoe leather and I wouldn't
know the difference we also have a bacon
Whopper
Jr which I they didn't give us also a
Big King which they did not give us I'm
certain I ordered it anyway we do have
is this the Rodeo Burger papow is a
burger with barbecue sauce and onion
rings man really generous of the onion
rings fun fact about the rodeo
cheeseburger it was created to coincide
with the release of the film Small
Soldiers in 1998 another fun fact in
1998 I worked at a movie theater in
shamberg Illinois that showed Small
Soldiers this was for some reason
brought out in time with that movie was
in the dollar menu stayed on the menu I
guess you can see why fun little burger
and the small solders chip Hazard which
is the name of the character I don't
even know his name was advertised it by
saying you can't handle the which just
like Jack Nicholson's line from A Few
Good Men you can't handle the truth here
are all the chicken items that you can
get a Burger King in Italy starting from
the crunch chicken fried chicken mayo
lassos and tomato you can also get a
chicken bacon King same thing as the um
beef one with a eight strips of bacon
next up we have the chicken roal with
bacon cheese why is this this shape does
this look Royal to you maybe it's just
easier to eat I don't know but I'm not
very intrigued a lot of mayo here and
then we got the crazy cheese chicken
bbec yeah there's definitely barbecue
sauce here and then we got a plant-based
nugget Burger which has mayo that is not
vegan because of obviously there's eggs
in there but there are three nuggets in
there
just quite funny like a nugget burger
here are most of the chicken options you
can get at the US Burger King starting
down here we got the BK Royal crispy
chicken every time we do a food Wars
Burger King's got a bunch of new chicken
sandwiches cuz they're trying to compete
with Chick-fil-A and if you ask me they
losing all right this looks epitome of
just okay we also have have a spicy
version of the same sandwich the spicy
BK Royal crispy sandwich this one looks
crispier much better not very spicy good
flavor to it get that one they also have
a bacon and swiss one which I think is
this one all right I'm want to get a
bite of the bacon in the
Swiss taste bacony typical to Burger
King something's popular so they make a
somewhat inferior version you can also
get the honey mustard BK Royal Crisp
Chicken blahy blah
this one also has bacon on it the Honey
Mustard's interesting we also have
chicken junr a little guy this is
basically uh the Ripoff of the McChicken
a far more Superior chicken
sandwich another menu item that was
available over the summer but may be off
the menu now certainly wasn't the BK we
went to here in Burbank was the Italian
BK Royal crispy chicken let's get that
picture up on the screen this would been
perfect for food Wars US versus Italy
couldn't get my hands on it Claudia what
do you think of this I don't know that
doesn't look very Italian to me I think
if you put crispy chicken that
automatically makes it all Italian let's
talk about wraps we thought they were
two uh actually the grilled chicken is
not uh there anymore so we just got this
crispy one this RS look very sad I don't
know I feel like you could do better
with the actual rub itself here's what
inside what's inside I don't know the
wrap is very pale BK also has wraps you
can get pretty much each one of these
chicken sandwiches in wrap form I went
ahead and got the spicy BK Royal crispy
wrap I mean all they're doing is taking
oh so it's half a Patty I a full Patty
so you get half a Patty and all stuff in
wrap form like what is the what's the
draw of this if you want a wrap just go
someplace else couple other exclusive
items that we got here you get a taco at
Burger King I love tacos just as much as
the next guy but I mean look how thin
this is look like the I sat on it before
he gave it to us I'm
curious I can't be sure but I think they
put the barbecue sauce in there that
can't be right if they did that's
terrible whatever it is is bad don't get
it this right here is the big fish look
at this thing what a nightmare they put
pickles on it guys come on pickles on a
fish sandwich I really like the filo
fish I should say that right now I think
it's a tasty sandwich I don't know what
they're putting in the fileo fish in
McDonald's probably not a lot of fish
but I think it's very good my favorite
thing about the f fish is their tarder
sauce it makes and breaks the sandwich
for them tarer sauce fantastic so one
would assume that this Square fish Patty
uh correct me or wrong but no fish is
naturally Square so this highly
processed fish Patty uh is drowning in a
white sauce that should be a tarder
sauce and we're going to find out if
it's any
good it's a thicker
bun it feels like getting more sandwich
um yeah actually kind of like that I
think it's better tasting than the flil
fish but still pretty good let's see
what it's in Italy's King Junior meal as
a main course you can either get a four
piece nugget a chicken burger a
hamburger a cheeseburger or a toast
which is what we got today and then you
also get fries a mini kit kat a drink
and a toy let's see what's inside ours
here's our
toast tiny
fries cute
kitat the drink obviously and a toy what
is this it's like a
glass it doesn't really look like
something you would give to your child
if you were making their lunch it is the
plainest thing that you can get and
usually parents are a little bit wary of
like giving sauces and like things that
are too rich kids meal options in the US
AKA The King Jor you can get either a
cheeseburger or a four piece nugget I
think we got the nuggets and then
options are either fries onion rings or
applesauce uh they have a drink cup that
is
reusable that think pretty nice and you
can also get milk see it says Junior
right there and for a
toy spoon no the toy they got nothing I
don't know if they forgot to give us a
toy or maybe they don't have
toys what like oh you think cuz I
ordered as an adult they're like he
doesn't want a
toy what all work and no play for the J
man come on I want a toy I think maybe
though you think the puzzle the toy in
the
big I don't
know so I don't think the spoon's the
toy so I forgot the toy you don't get
one we didn't get one exclusive sides we
have these are two of them uh one thing
I want to point everyone's attention to
are these chicken fries that's right
chicken strips shaped like
interesting fact about this box it kind
of like get smaller here this box was
designed specifically to fit in a car
cup holder cuz here in America God
forbid we stop and eat a meal we have to
eat and do something else I think it's
very funny consider in Italy it's like
the meal is the event it's a chicken fry
it's more of like a marketing thing to
call this a fry because it's not a
chicken tender because tenders come from
a specific part of the chicken the fres
is more like a chicken finger
where it's made with whole muscle meat
they're really durable they're really
elastic don't you think if you're waving
a piece of chicken like this it would
have broken off by now look at this look
at this why is this so like this I think
they taste fine it's just a weird thing
to be like on the menu still I don't
know anyone who's getting these
mozzarella sticks we should have asked
Claudia before do mozzarella sticks even
exist in Italy I want to know cuz here
in the US you can get these as a four
piece or an a piece with marinara sauce
these have been sitting for a while but
of course I'm wondering what kind of
cheese pull we can get from these
mozzarella
sticks
oh okay okay oh not a bad one that just
okay these are our exclusive sides here
in Italy starting from these chili
cheese bites you can get them in a six
piece and a nine piece doesn't look like
there's chili them let's try them
out they taste a bit too peppery I think
I was expecting it just to taste spicy
like they taste like fresh chilies which
is nice but I'm not sure which cheese is
this then we've got plant-based nuggets
as a six piece they look a bit green
like there's been like there from filter
on them they taste actually like nuggets
I don't know if this
is like fake chicken or it's just like
vegetable
vegetables but they're quite good and
from the inside they look like normal
ones you can then get bacon King fries
with cheddar sauce you can also get them
without cheddar sace but here's the ones
we've got you can also get chicken wings
in a four piece and a eight piece here's
how they look like just very tiny wings
when I was little we used to go in like
vacation in this town in like the south
of Italy like a very small village and
the whole village on the 15th of August
was celebrating with something that we
call the alata allaha means Wing in
Italian and it was just like a big
chicken wings party the ones I'm used to
they were a little bit bigger uh and a
bit more like light colored let's see
how these this ones tastes
like ooh
spicy it's like a bit Yeah like a bit of
a spicy sauce yeah there's a lot of
pepper in there no not a fun then you
can get two types of toast the king
toast with a Swiss cheese and ham this
is the same as in the kids menu and then
you can get it with bacon and American
cheese and then we've got griller fries
or maybe you call this waffle fries but
we actually have some packaged uh chips
in Italy they are sold with this shape
perhaps that's why they went with the
fries there is a tiny bit of spice um in
the after like in the aftertaste quite
nice they're doing waffle fries in Italy
that's a direct ripoff of the
Chick-fil-A fries like this company is
Shameless if it's popular somewhere else
Burger King has it that's their new
slogan and then we also have salads here
in Italy technically there are four
options but we were only able to get two
so the four options are just the mixed
salad
uh crispy chicken um grilled chicken and
a tuna salad which doesn't seem like
something I would like to get Burger
King here we have a mixed salad one
thing I just why are you serving the
salad with the whole tomato who eats
this like why and we have another one
here which was supposed to be the
grilled chicken I think but
uh it's another one of those mixed
salads with those huge Tomatoes The
salads can can also come with some olive
oil it was actually given to us in a
little sashed but we can't find it sace
talk sauce talk here are all the sauces
that are exclusive to Italy well
technically exclusive because they're
all from hindes um so you won't find
this in the US hind makes all the sauces
here in Italy we start from ketchup then
Mayo barbecue sweet and sour sauce Curry
mango sauce then we've got spicy tomato
salsa which um sounds interesting and
then we got cream honey mustard the last
one which is not made uh by hin is not
Chola this is technically not a sauce
it's like a hazelnuts and chocolate
spread a bit like Nutella yeah this one
Roni Diago is like some people say the
Posh Nutella it's a very nice and Rich
spread let's see mango and Curry the
color I was expecting
nice I'm surprised it's on the menu yeah
it does taste like Kye inspired sauce
and like sweet so maybe there is mango I
love the looks of the mango Curry I
definitely want one of those can you
please send it to me thank you here are
pretty much all the sauces you can get
in the US since they're not Hines
products at least not labeled do you
think Burger K can makes their own
sauces or you think they're just get
going to the source and putting their
own labels on it I have no idea here we
got a barbecue
sauce I would love to try when I go to
Europe like that's happening anytime
soon when I go to Europe I want to try
their barbecue sauces I feel like what
they think is barbecue and what we call
barbecue can't be the
same that's a sweet barbecue sauce I'd
like in like a Kansas City Barbecue very
good this is the zesty sauce this tastes
like a strong mustard not honey mustard
but sweeter than a regular mustard
actually it's Clos like a Dion it just
says spices doesn't say which ones um no
it's not bad just I don't want that
sweet and sour sauce come on oh open
like a normal imagine if I was driving
trying to my chicken
ah I be on the opposite side of the road
by now crashing everyone I be driving on
the sidewalk trying to open this the
sauce all right sweet and sour come on
Buffalo sauce for those you not in
America buffalo sauce is named after
Buffalo Hot Wings it's a type of spicy
sauce get wings and now it's on
everything and no it does not taste like
Buffalo it's from Buffalo New York where
the sauce was the recipe was made or
perfected I don't know so basically hot
wing
sauce I like buffalo sauce I don't think
it's only good on chicken and burgers or
fries are dipping doesn't work last we
got Ranch this country is obsessed with
ranch I don't know why um it's kind of
weird but we got everyone in America
including Burger King
so ranchy and this is a Hines ketchup
wait we have hin ketchup and they have
hind ketchup this is an
exclusive but these sauces are biscuits
here in the US we have a specific type
of biscuit that is not a cookie or a
scone it's its own thing anyway we can
get just about every breakfast sandwich
at Burger King in biscuit form there's
the bacon egg and cheese biscuit sausage
egg and cheese biscuit Smoky Maple
chicken biscuit the ham egg and cheese
biscuit the egg and cheese biscuit and
the fully loaded biscuit I'm not getting
all of them it's a waste here's two I
got the bacon egg and cheese biscuit
personally I think when it comes to
breakfast sandwich bacon egg and cheese
is the gold standard you can maybe do it
a different way but I think bacon egg
and cheese is pretty much the best
breakfast sandwich to get there it is
there's your egg there's your bacon and
cheese there's the biscuit it's very dry
I don't feel like trying it and then
also the fully loaded one this is
hilarious want to get this this got a
little bit of everything got the egg got
the sausage got the ham got the cheese
and the bacon how does this look Italy
huh breakfast is served let's go not
only do we have that in biscuit form we
have the same exact type of sandwiches
in croissant excuse me cro sandwich form
once again Italy your neighbors to the
north France they invented the croissant
I'm sure all through Europe you have
amazing pastries including croissants
here in the US we've absolutely ruined
them by cutting them in half and
sticking meat and cheese in the middle
so here we go we got the bacon egg and
cheese again the gold standard you also
get a ham egg and cheese egg and cheese
smoky Maple chicken Cris sandwich that's
horrible double sausage egg and cheese I
forgot about that that's two patties of
sausage two slices of cheese double the
diarrhea in the morning and of course
the fully loaded
sandwich a cricet buddy is
back we will try to remove the Cricut
audio in uh post but sorry everyone
we're filming this in the middle of the
woods apparently we have sausage egg ham
bacon cheese oh God
CRI do you want to buite to this we also
have breakfast burritos this here is the
egg normous burrito which has bacon egg
cheese a hash brown and a spicy sauce
this is for someone who just wants your
first hour once you punch in at work to
be on the toilet so if you're looking to
poop on company time maybe grab one of
these and I'll way to work look at this
guys this is
like I don't even know what this is like
I've never seen anything like this so of
course I have to try
it nope gross and this next
one is a breakfast burrito Jr so this
one's for kids when to get him started
young look what they did they put a hash
brown at the beginning and the end so
you're going to be
like oh it must be loaded with hash
browns one of the wanted the entrance in
the exit nice
also in the US we're crazy about
pancakes and we have the pancake platter
and the pancake and sausage platter
currently unavailable at the Burbank
Burger King in Italy we actually don't
have a breakfast menu of Burger King to
be honest I don't think Italians would
like to have what Joe has in his menu
like a crust on filled with bacon and
eggs doesn't seem quite right uh I think
most of us just have a sweet breakfast
usually is just the pastry and the
coffee it can be a very calorific pastry
with like a lot of Nutella or or another
feeling but usually it's always sweet
sounds like Claudia is implying that
Italians like something a little more
sweet a Bak good for breakfast so we do
have some of those in the US and we do
have some of those obviously have Burger
King going on down here starting off we
got French toast sticks France as you
are aware is a country that's right
above Italy and they have have their own
toast and we have that in Stick form and
this is them and it also comes with the
dipping syrup what's more French than
that look at this look at this I know
it's food Wars Italy but food Wars
France has got to be right around the
corner any french person watching this
right now is going to have a heart
attack but yeah you know I
mean you have no idea how sweet this is
uh also we have these hash brown bites
little
guys desserts sweet eats oh how we have
it in the us at our Burger King uh you
can get a Hershey's Sunday pie not
Sunday day of the week Sunday as in uh
like a ice cream sunday right and I mean
I mean look at this look at this right
look at this how gooey that is ooh come
on also at Burger King you can get soft
serve ice cream I didn't get it because
we've been in the studio for a couple
hours and it's very hot and it would
have melt M anyway you can also get
chocolate chip cookies hey and a variety
of shakes a vanilla shake a chocolate
shake a chocolate Oreo shake and this
the Oreo shake every time we do a fast
food place that has a shake that the
Oreo shake I get it I think that Oreo as
far as branded cookies snack shakes you
get a lot of these fast food places the
Oreo is the best one why do you ask
looks like a vanilla and chocolate shake
right wrong it isn't vanilla it's the
it's the Oreo cream flavored shake with
Oreo chocolate cookies in it just I'm
telling
you oh my God so good Oreo is the best
shake hands down M so on to the dessert
options here in Italy these are the ones
that we were able to get but actually
there are a bunch of others and we're
going to put them all on screen here
that includes a lot of ice cream like
sanday and milkshakes but we were not
able to to get them so this is what
we've got today we've got noata pancakes
and then we've got nauy uh cheesecake
Crown caramel sule I think if you call
something lava cake you would expect I
mean I'm sure like half of your
customers will think that you actually
put lava in there yeah and I was saying
earlier Nota is actually a very popular
spread here in Italy it's like a Haz and
nut and chocolate spread I was expecting
it to be much
thicker let's
see
quite
nice yeah the P pancakes are okay it's
really delicious it tastes much strong
like much more like like hazelnuts than
Nutella does like these two are like
competitors approved we can also get
some milkshakes the exclusive ones are
NES quick NES Cafe and Oreo drinks to
the US Burger King we have a lot
Fountain drinks for instance it's a
fountain drink C up I wasn't going to
get all these cuz it's just super hot
it's pain in a butt to get the stuff
here all the other drinks have melted
told you I'm wearing the shirt it's hot
in here we have something called frozen
drinks you get a frozen Coke and a
frozen wild cherry and also Frozen blue
raspberry which is not available um this
was more of a slush consistency for
melted in this 80 Dee Studio what oh we
also got milk okay anyway
um not bad I mean still pretty cold but
yeah usually this is a lot more like ice
like icy as a wild cherry oh yeah we
have coffee drinks you can get an iced
coffee this used to have ice in it and a
hot coffee and of course who doesn't
like to relax with a room temperature
fat free milk that'll wash down your
burger here are all the drinks that are
exclusive to Italy Burger King starting
from this very cute P orange juice then
we got some uh some tea we've got Peach
and Rose fancy and lemon and
lemongrass we've got Monster Energy uh
which has been delivered in a bit of a
funny shape and then we've got beer you
can either get hinin or ikusa which is a
Sardinian beer some Burger Kings will
also serve a full range of coffees
espresso coffees CU that's what coffeee
means to us uh but because we got our
food and drinks that delivered we
actually were not able to select coffee
so we couldn't get any
today B King in my point of view is like
Fast food's little brother it's always
like trying to trying to be like the big
dogs it's always trying to be like
McDonald's it's always like whatever is
Good Burger King has like kind of a
later crummier version of it now I will
say the Whopper is a fantastic sandwich
I love the Whopper I get it occasionally
but everything else on Burger King's
menu thumbs down or at least there's
something else that's better than
whatever they're offering you know
Burger King I only eat there when it's
the ultimate convenience which is rare
because I don't know if a lot of people
outside of the US knew this but Burger
King's strategy is to build a location
close to a McDonald's did you know that
so McDonald's does all this research
about where to position their restaurant
strategically you know traffic patterns
uh rent and locations all that stuff
McDonald's is a whole department of
people to figure that out and then
Burger King's like all right we'll build
one across the street from the
McDonald's that's for real like that's
their Vibe on everything so I don't know
it's like in other countries but in
Burger King you're just like a Burger
King in Italy I think Burger King goes
pretty much hand inand with McDonald's
um obviously it's been there for a
little bit less time Burger King is
quite popular in Italy they currently
have 200 132 Outlets KFC has only got 50
branches here in Italy although they are
still behind McDonald's that has 630
branches like some of us have most of us
have celebrated birthdays at McDonald's
so obviously we do have some memories
and like something that bring us brings
us back to it I think it's also a little
bit more expensive compared to McDonalds
and maybe that's one of the reasons why
people would choose one instead of the
other even though there are some Italian
ingredients in the menu Burger King is
still pretty much
considered the American option or like
the American fast food chain uh whereas
McDonald's has sort of got got rid of
the American fast food chain is just the
fast food chain if that makes sense they
are the first chain that has removed
preservatives and colorants from food
but there are quite a few items that
we've seen today that look very shiny
and like very color F and I would really
like to know how do you make your cheese
so yellow without colorance like why
like how how is that even possible
naturally
Rivals I don't know would you consider
McDonald's rival that's like me saying
the Rocks My Rival like yeah Rivals but
like come on I don't think he's sweating
that I'm out there doing doing videos as
well uh there's no there's no no no
one's I mean Wendy's I
guess let's talk about prices in Italy a
Whopper is
650 which is about
$727 if you want to make that a meal
with a medium siiz drink and medium
fries that's going to cost you €1 and
that's about
$12.30 and in the US a Whopper will cost
you
$689 or6 €6 16 Euro bytes I don't know
what the what is that sense all right
everyone relax it's C there you go all
right so
€66 now that's a 6% decrease in price
how do you like that if you're making a
meal with a medium fries as a medium
drink it will cost you
$12.18 or
€195 so it actually works out cheaper to
get a Whopper meal in the US rather than
in Italy but just buy a few cents 12
bucks uh I guess I'm used to it but you
come to think of it it's a lot more
expensive than what I initially thought
yeah I mean I don't think it's that good
of AA it's not like too expensive but I
think like 13 bucks or whatever 12
something plus tax for all this it's
like G might as well get something
better the prices seem fair it is a
little bit more expensive than
McDonald's but also the burgers are a
little bit bigger and it's definitely
almost half the price as like a Five
Guys I think € 11 years is fair but if
you start getting close to like 15
that's where I think I would like to sit
down at a restaurant and that's probably
the price of like a main course like a
restaurant here in Milan so 11 years was
just below just below like the
restaurant line let's
say as the Whopper is Burger King's
number one bestselling item we thought
we will compare them nutritionally in
Italy a Whopper contains 683 calories
our us Whopper contains all this if you
make that a meal by adding medium fries
and a medium Coke the total is this
making the grand total this the most
calorific item on the menu here is the
bacon King 3.0 at
1,342 calories that is a lot for a
burger our bacon King is also the most
calor fix single item on the menu at
1,200 calories o from calorie to portion
sizes we wanted to find out all the
differences between Five Guys in Italy
and the US this is food
Wars burgers in Italy come in two sizes
little and regular little has one Patty
and regular has two our Burgers also
come in two sizes little and regular
let's weigh a regular plain hamburger in
both countries to see who has the bigger
Burgers that's uh
136 G
138 G the burger mark is really
off-putting any difference might be down
to the patties Five Guys actually tells
us that the US patties should weigh
about 94 gr each or 3.3 o although this
will be the weight before cooking the
Five Guys Italy website says that the
patties when uncooked should weigh 67 G
so we're going to see if that's true
obviously this have been cooked so the
meat should have released some fat but
going to find out soon this is a Five
Guys Hot Dog it looks a little weird
because they slice them down the middle
to cook them I really love how these
cook when they're sliced let's measure
the length first that's about 16.2 CM I
think that's about 15 cm yeah 6 in we
don't use inches
anything now let's weigh the plain hot
dog that is 144 G we're now going to
weigh it so just for reference we put
mustard ketchup and onions in this sof
dog so obviously it's going to be B
heavier than a regular one let's see 195
G our fries come in three sizes in
either plain or cajun spice you can get
little regular or large our Five Guys
fries come in three sizes either plain
or with Kajun spice little regular and
large according to Five Guys the little
should weigh 227 G let's see if that's
true it's not it's 82 G this is 82 oh
wait yeah it's 82 G our little fries
should weigh 256 G 103 G so we did ask a
Five Guys employee about how they
package their fries they scoop the fries
into one of these cups put that in the
bag and then they do another scoop of
fries on top I think so that could be
the reason why some of these weights are
off there's just like fried everywhere
don't really know which fry came from
which cup it's a mess we're supposed to
have
1,225 G all together but right now we're
sitting at 870 G including the extra
fries which aren't really extra so our
total should have been 1,220 G but we
got 580 G so that's less than half
milkshakes in Italy come in one size and
this is supposed to be 400 ml so this is
the vanilla milkshake in the US us I
believe we only have one size of
milkshake so let's see how much we get
it's actually almost 500 I'll say it's
like
ml something around
that here's everything you'll find at
Five Guys in the US that you won't find
in Italy here's everything you find at
Five Guys Italy that you won't find in
the US the owners of Five Guys like to
keep the restaurants and the menus all
the same so there aren't any exclusive
Burger options in the us this is the
Five Guys burger menu so our Burger
menus are almost exactly the same the
only difference is that here you can
order two additional patties not just
one uh so you end up with a burger with
four patties in it I'm not sure you can
do that in the US maybe if you ask
nicely but it's an official feature here
since Five Guys is known for its
customizable options you probably could
order two extra patties for your burger
but we'll let you have this one Claudia
but see seeing as America doesn't have
official exclusive menu items Five Guys
enthusiasts had to get creative and make
their own in the form of an unofficial
secret menu so this is the patty melt
it's a grilled cheese sandwich with an
extra Patty inside it looks kind of good
to me I love when restaurants do grilled
cheeses with the Buns of the burgers I
think it tastes so
good I feel like I like this better than
the Five Guys Burgers it's something
about the way the bread gets all toasty
it just makes it so much more delicious
so next is the artery Annihilator that's
a little ridiculous so we have to put a
bacon hot dog inside of a bacon
cheeseburger how I'm going to do that I
don't know what I think is right is
making it edible in some form so I'm
just going to like break it up a
little I'm trying to squish it down cuz
it's not going to fit into my mouth
okay
this literally sucks like don't order
this there's no reason for you if you
want a hot dog and a burger a
burger let me swallow this stupid bite
of food hold on I feel like putting the
hot dog into the burger doesn't make it
taste any better it just makes it a lot
harder to eat and a lot less enjoyable
of an experience so I think this is
really not fun or good to me I think
this should be at the top so let's try
double bread yeah there's a
s right so here's your Italian version
artery Annihilator right I don't know I
feel like this is annihilating my
eyesight as well on top of my arteries
if I were to try
[Music]
it too much stuff Five Guys is of course
famous for its wide selection of Free
Toppings according to Five Guys there
are over 250,000 ways to customize your
burger now these aren't exclusive
toppings but here's what you can get the
only exclusive topping we have in
America is A1 Sauce in Italy the
toppings are almost exactly the same as
in the us but we do have one exclusive
sauce which is the HP Sauce according to
chefs at 5 Guys when customizing your
burger there's a specific way it has to
be stacked within their rules it should
be the bottom bun then any wet items
like grilled onions or mushrooms then
the first Patty two slices of cheese
then another Patty then dry items like
lettuce tomatoes and jalapenos go on top
and then there's the top bun to finish
it all off let's see if it came in the
order that it's supposed to come in so
at the bottom I see the grilled onions I
see grilled mushrooms and I also see
peppers green peppers so it's already
out of order because the jalapenos are
on the bottom for some reason I feel
like I don't know I feel like this if it
doesn't affect the taste I personally do
not care but if it's their law in the
Five Guys then I guess you should be
doing it I don't know all right so we
got the first Patty the two slices of
cheese another Patty and then on top we
have the lettuce and tomatoes let's
check if the order is the same here in
Italy so yes we got bottom bun onions
and mushrooms we got a Patti cheese we
got another
Patti tomatoes and lettuce at the top
good job Five Guys Five Guys also offers
sandwich options there aren't any
exclusive sandwiches in the US but
here's what you can get so we have a
grilled cheese a BLT and a veggie
sandwich veggie
sandwich it's not bad it's just a little
too vegetable heavy for me
no next is the BLT which if you mess
this
up yeah it tastes like an okay BLT it
just mostly tastes like bacon and then
we have the grilled cheese which I think
will be good because I already liked the
patty melt and they're like
sisters that's a really good grilled
cheese we do have one exclusive in Italy
which is a be tea sandwich with cheese
which is supposed to be this one uh but
uh there's been a bit of a mixup in the
order um and the one we got has just
cheese and a l of bacon there aren't any
exclusive Five Guys Hot Dog options in
either country but here's what you can
get a hot dog a bacon dog a cheese dog
or a bacon cheese dog I've never had a
hot dog with cheese on it so I am kind
of intrigued I will say though I am a
fan of the slicing the hot dog and
putting like this side on the griddles
just so everything gets nice and crispy
I think they do taste better that
way it's not for me something about the
cheese and the hot dog mixing together
feels wrong cuz i' I I've never had it
it feels weird so this is is the uh
bacon and cheese hot dog looks pretty
good to me but I'm not I'm not really
familiar with hot dogs I think in
general in Italy we don't really have
that many like definitely burgers are
more
popular yeah maybe with some sace it
would be a bit better in the US we have
two exclusive milkshake options the Oreo
creme and the double stuff which I am
very excited about I love Oreos and Oreo
milkshakes are objectively the best
milkshake let's try the Oreo creme first
so this is just like the filling of the
Oreos essentially okay give it a good
swirl and it is creme and not
cream that is literally so good you're
actually drinking the creeme inside of
an Oreo next is double stuff so I assume
this has the creme and also a bunch of
Oreo pieces in it oh my God this is the
best one at Five Guys you can actually
add bacon to any of their milkshakes
flavors this is a vanilla bacon I just
feel like vanilla seemed like the
easiest thing to pair with the bacon
I've never tried this before but let's
see it tastes like vanilla and bacon I'm
just trying to decide mentally if that's
like something I should have eaten we
thought we had one exclusives in the
milkshake Department in Italy on their
website is still states that there is a
coffee milkshake that you can order we
did order it but then we got uh when we
got to the store to collect it turns out
it's been discontinued and it's been
years they haven't done it so please
update your website 5 Guys we still got
a bacon milkshake and then we on the
website also it lets you add every
single flavor so we got a milkshake with
absolutely everything that was available
what's in here there is Oreos banana
strawberry there's like so many
different things that just in my mind
they don't really work
together I think there's just too many
things to even make out what stuff is to
be honest is not too bad now we've got
the bacon milkshake mixing bacon with
milk it's it does sound a bit ridiculous
like I'm a bit disappointed though cuz I
don't really taste the bacon much we
also have some drink options you can
only get in the US simply lemonade root
beer and Dr Pepper do Italians like root
beer that's what I would love to know
you know what that is is I'm sure they
do if you're Italian from Italy comment
down below and tell me if you know what
rubir is one and two do you actually
think it's good because here people love
it and here are all the drinks that you
can only find in Italy we've got Fanta
orange sparkling water and then four
beers so let's talk about prices now in
Italy at Five Guys a cheeseburger will
cost you €1
1345 translated $ do that is4
$182 so for comparison at McDonald's you
can get a cheeseburger for €2 so yeah
for the same price 13 something you
could get six of these at the other
chain that's maybe too cheap but €13 for
a burger in team foil just sort of all
squished together still at a fast food
chain that's way way uh over what I
would pay in the US a cheeseburger will
cost you $11
.79 or
€1.7 that is a 26% decrease in price so
Five Guys is doing this thing where all
of their food is fresh and made to order
they're trying to kind of raise the
standard of what fast food could be I
think that's why their prices are on the
higher end although I don't know if
that's fully Justified because I can say
that I've had better cheaper Burgers I
think that's allow and to make that a
meal so with a regular fries and a drink
that will cost you €23 20 which in
dollars is
$25.56 again so overpriced like23 for
all
this and I still don't even have a plate
it's just a lot a lot to make it a meal
with regular fries and a regular drink
it will cost you
$214 C or €1
1948 I it's just not making sense to me
$21 for a fast food burger fries and
drink no absolutely
not let's take a look at some of the
basic ingredients at Five Guys Italy in
Italy the burger itself is 100% ground
beef and in the US a burger actually
contains 8020 USDA ground chuck if you
want to add cheese to you Burger though
here's everything that's in the cheese
Five Guys cheese in the US contains all
of these
ingredients let's look at the bun it
contains water salt sugar vegetable
shortening milk eggs bleached bread
flour yeast and sesame seeds so in Italy
the bun has a total of 11 ingredients
that's two more than the US the
additional ingredients are calcium
carbonate and spirit vinegar the only
difference in the hot dogs is some of
the ingredients to make the pink
coloring we love dying our food here the
ingredients for the fries are really
simple it's just potatoes refined peanut
oil and salt if you go to a Five Guys
they have this little board that tells
you where your potatoes are coming from
that day and ours came from St Anthony
Idaho and the fries at five guys are
very simple there are potatoes peanut
oil and salt it's the first thing that I
see something cooked with peanut oil
let's see do they taste like peanuts at
all or actually they taste quite potato
like they taste quite nice yeah maybe
it's the peanut oil after
all in the US a cheeseburger that has a
bun two patties two pieces of cheese and
no toppings comes out to about 984
calories the total fat comes out to
about 55 G carbs 39 G sugar 8 G and
sodium
1,50 mg in Italy a regular cheeseburger
contains 7 56 calories of which 45 G are
total fat 40 G are carbs 8 G are sugar
and 98 mg our sodium and if you make
that a meal you can add fries and uh
they contain
1,22 calories then 66 G of fat 120 g of
carbs 1.7 g of sugar and 700 116 mg of
sodium our regular fries are 953
calories 41 G of fat 131 G of carbs 4 g
of sugar and 962 mg of sodium and a
chocolate milkshake contains
874 calories then 39 G of fat 121 G of
carbs 108 g of sugar and 48 8 mg of
sodium and a chocolate milkshake is 830
calories 36 G of fat 116 G of carbs 107
g of sugar and 400 mg of sodium so the
total for a meal that includes a
cheeseburger regular fries and the
milkshake is
2752 calories of which 150 g are total
fat then 281 gram carbs 118 gram of
sugar and
2,32 mg of sodium bringing the total to
2767 calories 132 G of total fat 286 G
of carbs 119 g of sugar and
2,412 mg of sodium well the numbers for
the fries are actually based on what is
uh stated on the website and we got
basically half of what is Staten there
so if you want to make this a little bit
more accurate you should have the uh
nutrition nutrition numbers as
well Five Guys first opened in Italy in
2018 in Milan just behind the dwo so a
very touristic uh location and then it
2021 after a bit of a covid break he
opened in Rome and there are now another
four locations in Milan I think well
starting with Milan is a very smart
choice obviously uh it's the most most
International City there's a lot of
tourists like fashion capital of Italy a
lot of offices uh a lot of foreigners as
well here which is maybe the reason why
they open here I know Five Guys is
available in a lot of places but
something about The Branding and the way
the food is presented feels very East
Coast to me I think it's because the
fries remind me of Boardwalk fries that
you'd get down at the Jersey Shore it's
a little weird because some stuff has
the Five Guys logo on it and you can
tell where it's from other stuff like
the fries and the burgers just come in
regular foil a regular unmarked cup so
it's like it's not a lot of brand
recognition at least for me I've never
even seen a Five Guys advertisement I've
never seen a commercial I've never
gotten an ad once you take like this cup
away you probably wouldn't know where I
got this food from because their burgers
are made to order it does take longer
for you to get your order I've waited
like at least 10 minutes for my order
out of five guys before so it's not like
the fastest fast food option but the
food is as fresh as it can be it kind of
gives me the feeling of food you'd get
at a concession stand at like a local
baseball game at a school or something
it's definitely got its own thing going
on from calorie count to portion sizes
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Pringles in Italy
and the US this is food
Wars here are all the exclusive flavors
that you will find in Italy that you
won't get in the US here are all the US
Pringles you're not going to find in
Italy starting from paprika I've got to
say paprika is something that's very
popular in
Spain yeah it's quite nice actually for
those who may don't know what paprika is
it's actually dried uh crushed red
pepper very fruity and fresh in a way I
know you guys in the US have a barbecue
flavor we actually have Texas barbecue
I don't know is there maybe any
difference or maybe this is just
marketing to appeal to the Italians
because when you say Texas
barbecue feels cooler and we already
know what it
is I don't know it's barbecue sauce
again it's barbecue sauce in Texas
supposed to taste different the US
actually has dozens of regional barbecue
Styles including Texas which has at
least four so it depends on who you ask
and I don't know where barbecue started
yeah we also have just
barbecue and I described the
Tangy good though I love barbecue and
then onto the exclusive train we've got
ketchup H I think it's a bit too strong
I prefer the other ones the queen of
them all the pizza flavored as I should
be I'm a little bit worried about those
because as an Italian I'm very vocal
about what pizza is I have pretty low
expectations for these just because
everything Pizza flavor to me it's like
a bit of a
gimmick
no they just taste like oregano so I
don't know why you guys have this idea
that like Italians love oregano so much
like I have so many spices and like
herbs in my kitchen and guess what's
missing oregano weirdly and maybe I'm
going to be cancelled for this but the
ketchup ones taste more like pizza
because they taste more like tomatoes
then we've got Smokey
bacon they taste more like the oil we
will cook the bacon in no fun you may
also be able to find emal Pringles but
we were not able to track them down so
ental is a Swiss cheese made in the
German part of Switzerland oh cheddar
cheese let's go first thing with
flavor get that on screen good oo I've
never had this one before hot
honey nope ah shatter and sour cream
dude these are always good M the chave
Sal vinegar got Ranch not the best Ranch
flavored chip out there but not bad I
think Claudia should try these y Claudia
catch
yeah thanks Joe I've actually never had
ranch sauce or like
dressing I can already see people sort
of walking away from me the moment I
start talking to them cuz the onion the
onion it's like very potent no I'm
seeing FL Nam on both of these I'm seen
a grill so assumption is these are spicy
enchilada
adobadas and the lamus
haban not a lot of heat to them but
pretty good I don't that tastes like an
enchilada
but these are good they're not like
Takis but they're really Takis spaces
but spicy have a a flaming hot Cheeto
kind of vibe to it Minecraft suspicious
stew limited time only thank God looks a
little gamer headset on there
Shameless Julius Pringle Shameless going
after the
kids I'm surprised for something that's
clearly marketed as kids this is not
have a very strong strong flavor to it
tastes like a weak sour Fram onion
Philly cheese steak check out the best
cheese steak in Philadelphia Food Tours
episode starting myself and Harry and
this is that sandwich in chip form I
can't imagine one human being wanting
this avoid this oh smells terrible
there's also a french fries and ketchup
and everything bagel flavor we were not
able to get for the shoe let's
get we also have a Lon of Fortune I in
apostrophe Pringles you can see the
steam coming out of julius's ears this
one he's crying he's crying the Buffalo
one he's not crying in the other ones
okay some look forward to start down
here with the
barbecue come on get
hot nope not scorching try the cheddar
I mean they even have the temperature
thing in the logo the thermometer going
up not only they not scorching but also
I'm not really getting any flavor I a
cheddar sour cream and onion I mean I
love sour cream and onion
they taste like sour cream onion
chips but I mean I'm getting a little
like lowlevel spice this one as you can
see Julius Pringle is crying look at
this the chip the pepper and the bottle
of hot sauce are all on
fire a little bit of heat yeah there it
is there it is okay I guess look for the
tears if you want spicy Pringles chili
and
lme now instead of scorching in Italy
spicy Pringles are called Flame and you
can find them as a spicy BBQ flavor and
cheese and chili
flavor I think I'll I'll be able to have
a few without without having to go and
drink but I think it's manageable it's
like a very manageable spice let's try
the cheese and chili now this one has
have two chilies on them so they're
supposed to be like the mild is ones
whereas these have
three M you're like attacked by this
cheese taste like cheese flavoring like
fake cheese taste like not nice also in
the US you can get something called the
Pringles Harvest blend four varieties to
choose from According to the ad copy a
deliciously complex tasting experience
unlike one you've ever had
B ARF they're potato chips let's embark
on this taste Journey unlike any
other
H The Taste difference between these two
are hardly noticeable but they
definitely look different Homestyle
Ranch also multigrain Amazon this guy
drop kicked this to my front door this
is
ridiculous these are different than the
regular Ranch and I do like these
flavors not as strong not as insane
which I I like sweet potato these next
door sweet potato and this is sea salt I
like that I like sweet
potatoes I like Maracas so okay again
the sweet potato smoky
barbecue I've definitely experienced
this before so I want to update that ad
copy the last exclusives we have is the
Lighter Side range where you can get the
lightly salted and the reduced fat
original could not get them for the time
of filming and honestly I'm glad not
interested in less salt or less fat
forget it so if I were to rank them all
let's see okay worst Pizza didn't like
the
bacon didn't like this one with the
cheese let's put the other spicy one
just because I'm I'm not so big on
spices then I'm going to put the ketchup
I'm going to put this one here and
probably the paprika is the one that I
will reach out for okay in no particular
order my favorites of the day were the
uh Lair Mir habaneras very good taking
these home cheddar and sour cream always
good
scorching series a little disappointed
except for the Buffalo my gu crying on
there so you know that they're scorching
and I did like the Harvest blend ones
the sweet potato ones I sign off them
here's what sucked hot honey not hot
very little honey the Philly cheese
stick thing yeah you can't and this
Minecraft suspicious stew I don't I'm
not eating anything called suspicious
that's just
weird in Italy our Pringles come in four
sizes we've got a 40 G small size you
may also be able to find a and go 70 G
tube but we were not able to track it
down and then you can also get them in
the 175 G standard tube but if you get
the flame spicy Pringle range you only
get for the standard tube 160 G even
though the tubes look exactly the same
maybe it not protect you sometimes
Pringles releases a 3ot tube which
always breaks the internet when it
actually comes out sadly it was not in
stores right now but it looks like it's
just three tubes stacked on top of one
another so visually this is what you
will
get here in the US our Pringles come in
five sizes snack stack another little
one the grab and go the original
tubey stack that means that the biggest
American size is 10% larger than the
biggest Italian one we wanted to find
out how many Pringles are in a tube but
we didn't really want to count them one
by one so we're going to weigh them and
do some LS we should be getting
87.5 Pringles in each tube well the five
is maybe some like crumbles the numbers
as we've crunched here at the food Wars
math lab is 149 G total and if one chip
is 1.9 G that equals 78.4 chips on
average per
tube in Italy the original Pringles
contain the following the original
Pringles in the US contain all of this
there aren't any major differences
except for actually coloring that we do
add to our Pringles here in Italy it's
anato uh it's made from plants and it's
totally natural I mean anato is very
dark it's like a flashy orangey Brown so
still very far from this coloring but
there is a difference with the US the
longest ingredient list for Pringles in
the US are these the scorching sour
cream and onion with 47 ingredients good
God 11 of these are main ingredients and
36 are sub ingredients now many of these
are flavoring spices and different dairy
products to create the cream flavor as
well as some colorings which you may not
have heard of before red 40 Yellow 5 and
yellow 6 there's new evidence that red
40 is triggering inflammatory bowel
disease because it is disrupting the way
the gut barrier works which is harmful
and encourages inflammation first it
scorches your tongue and then it
scorches your bow UK manufacturers were
made to remove this from their products
however it can be legally sold by EU
Imports providing it is properly labeled
may have an adverse effect on activity
and attention in children yellow number
five also called tarine is a type of
sodium salt then when eaten it becomes
sulfenic acid it is this acid that can
cause allergic reactions especially in
asmatic people and can produce eczema
hives and also hyperactivity in children
many Nordic countries have banned its
use but is approved in the US and UK
heads up Harry yellow number six also
called Sunset yellow or
e110 is similar to tarine and these
colors have appeared in a bunch of
flavors these
specifically obviously Pringles is a
very well-known brand in Italy but I
think the idea of chips as a thing for
us chips are not really a thing of their
own they're like part of a family family
of snacks in Italy we tend to have chips
on like a snack board with other things
other items like olives or tiny pieces
of fuka Pringles is not the first brand
that I will reach out to it's funny cuz
to me all these seem quite a big number
having to decide between like three four
five six s seven flavor flavors and then
you got the original it's a lot we just
saw the 500 different flavor they have
Pringles they're doing every flavor good
for them but as far as the classics the
salt and vinegar the barbecue the
cheddar sour cream and onion I feel like
Pringles is pretty good at uh doing most
flavors but they also had the stupid
Minecraft flavor so I don't know I don't
know they are exclusive to the Italian
market but they still do seem adapted to
the Italian market versus created for
the Italian market if you want to
something very Italian you should have
put an olive oil one like you're really
missing an opportunity here just put an
olive oil flavored chip we we've talked
about some food Wars before in America
chips and snacks are all going after
each other they might be owned by the
same company and they're just like
cross-pollinating but the chip bio is
just all filled with these different
iterations of the same kind of ideas so
I see tube snacks all the time I've got
actually here some of the most popular
ones we've got funes which are like
pretty much like chips you know then way
this is a very traditional Italian chip
you also find this it's this are cros
this is like dried bread you know it's
like a bit like crumbs you know do you
say like Crouton especially in the south
of Italy where I'm from body we make
these all the time they're called tarali
shape is always the same but you always
get them in different flavors actually
my Grandma makes them and it's like the
best thing ever and they're made with
flour olive oil and wine so this is like
the absolute OG Italian
snack the best my grandma's is are
better but this is
good in the US our original regular tube
the 5.2 o or the 149 G is currently $2
at Walmart in Italy our original
Pringles in the 175 G St will cost you
€230 that's about
$247 that means that in Italy we get a
23% price increase although we do get a
few more grams we want to see how much
our biggest portion of Pringles will
cost for a 48 snack stack cup variety
pack it cost $29 72 divide that by 48
and each snack stack cost 62 hey uh
Claudia just out of curiosity for common
Italian snack foods how do Pringles
compare in price compared to other
snacks that you can get in Italy for
example the tarali they actually quite
expensive and you do get only 175 gram
things like these they usually sold at
bakeries for like 23 per kilo so that's
quite a lot of
difference in the US 100 G of original
Pringle chips contain all this that's
almost half of your recommended fat
intake for the deck in Italy a 100 G
portion of original Pringles contains
the following our version actually
contains more sugar than the US one but
slightly less fat and sodium across all
Pringles flavors for calories they're
all pretty much the same now some have 1
G extra of carbs and the sodium is the
only thing that fluctuates between
flavors in Italy the flavor with the
most sodium is ketchup a 100 G serving
contains 750 Mig of sodium in the US our
saltiest flavor is the lasir mirus
habaneras with
1,17 mg that's nearly half of your daily
allowance from exclusive items to
portion sizes we wanted to find out all
the differences between Starbucks in
Italy and the US this is food
Wars our hot drinks in Italy come in
four sizes short tall Grande and venty
our hot drinks come in five sizes short
tall Grande ventti and the coffee
traveler two of these like Grande and
venti are Italian words like venti means
20 in Italian and Grande just means big
let's measure them out to
see the name translates to 20 but is not
in the US iced coffees come in four
sizes tall Grande venti and Trenta
Trenta is not available as an option for
their espresso drinks but you can get it
in stuff like cold brew or their Iced
Teas our iced coffees come in three
sizes a t Grande and ventti let's
measure the vti to see if it actually is
20 ounces 18 ounces so again not a true
venti it's more like a dto which is like
18 we're also going to waste some
popular food items from Starbucks let's
start with the butter
croissant so it's a pretty big
difference to how much Italy weighs it's
a lot smaller another popular Bakery
item is the blueberry muffin let's see
what it
weighs
here's everything that you find at
Starbucks in Italy that you won't find
in the US here's everything that you'll
find at a Starbucks in the US that you
won't find in Italy we know that
Starbucks is popular because of its
customization options so because of that
we're only going to look at the official
menus in the US and Italy these are the
exclusive hot drinks that you can find
at Starbucks here in Italy starting from
this tiny cup uh this one is barley
coffee in Italian we call it Cafe DTS
and it's basically an alternative to
Espresso for those people that cannot
really drink coffee it has the look of
coffee I'm not a fan of this I think you
know if because I can drink noral coffee
so but if I were not able to I think
I'll just force myself to like it just
for the you know pleasure of still
having my espresso and then we have a
vanilla latte it does smell just like
just like a cappuccino really but
obviously it's like past 11 or so so
it's like past breakfast time anyway so
cappuccinos are like a no no drink for
me I'm not so much into like drinking
milk after a certain time of the day and
then we have latte macchiato and then we
have this one this one is a Sal salted
Maple and caramel
latte it's just smells like sugar it's
nice yeah it does taste like fake
artificial syrup and then we got some
teas we got T van English breakfast
jasmine pearl hibiscus or ibiscus as we
say here and camomo and you may also be
able to find the Moroccan which in
Italian just translates into like
literally marokino it's like a tiny
cappuccino in a way there's like a bit
of coffee and a bit of milk obviously
with like its own like proper ratio and
it's named weirdly after a Moroccan
leather that has the same color that
this coffee has it's like a brownish
like brown leather that's actually very
popular here in the northern region in
Milan where we are so here are the hot
exclusive beverages we bought today this
is the caramel apple spice juice the
apple crisp oat milk macchiato we have a
blonde vanilla Latt and this is a royal
English breakfast tea we also have these
exclusive hot drinks I feel like I have
to try this caramel apple spice juice
because it looks nothing like juice so
so I'm
interested I think it's just hot apple
cider it doesn't taste bad actually that
tastes pretty good I'm going to try the
Royal English breakfast tea in honor of
Harry it's not my favorite but my
preference is iced tea not hot tea so
maybe that's why and I also like them a
lot sweeter we have lots of exclusive
cold drinks here in Italy we didn't get
everything but here's what we've got
starting from a cookies and cream
Frappuccino I'm quite surprised this is
exclusive to Italy cuz I always
associate cookies and cream with the
US it has held it shape in the delivery
to me this this is a bit of a foreign
idea cuz we just have the boring
chocolate
flavor yeah like chocolate cookies nice
it's like a childhood memory here are
all the fraps that we got so we we have
the chai cream this is the mocha cookie
frap this is the apple crisp frap the
pumpkin spice fra and the white mocha
cream frap I feel very compelled to try
this mocha cookie frap because it just
looks like a milkshake it looks like
dessert there's literally cookie
crumbles in
it yeah it tastes like cold chocolate
milk specifically Nestle syrup chocolate
milk an apple crisp Frappucino know
sounds kind of special to me so I really
want to taste it kind of tastes like a
candle I don't like that not at all but
I tried it the pumpkin spice wrap and
the apple crisp wrap are seasonal items
so you're not going to be able to find
them year round and then we have iced
cold foam
cappuccino um we don't really have a lot
of foam here it also looks quite dark
for capuccino but maybe that's just
because the foam is gone but I don't
know they keep putting hearts here but
I'm not really tempted to try this and
then we have an iced salted Maple and
caramel lter does does smell a lot
like sugar actually not even like Maple
it actually just smells like sugar and
you can see the sugar at the top I did
live in Canada for one year let's see if
it does actually taste like Maple I
don't know if I can advocate for like
Canadians out there but for what is
worth I'm going to try it there's no
Maple in there definitely no it's like
sugar not even caramel just a lot lot of
sugar I feel like a Canadian would never
order this but that will be another
episode of food Wars and then we have
iced chai tea oat latte again quite
surprised that this is exclusive to
Italy cuz we're not so big on like chai
I don't know for some reason I really
like chai as like the tea version but
I've never really quite liked it with
milk so we have cold brew but we also
have Nitro cold brw which which are a
little bit frothier and thicker than the
regular cold brew this is the pumpkin
cream cold brew this is the cinnamon
caramel cream Nitro cold brew and here
we have the vanilla sweet cream Nitro
cold brew I already know that I love the
pumpkin cream cold brew I kind of want
to try this cinnamon caramel
one no not for me it's a little weirdly
sweet for something that doesn't have
any milk in it I don't think let me try
this one this one's really good I really
like the vanilla sweet cream cold Ro
that just tastes like a really good
foamy coffee we then have this one the
Very Berry hibiscus refresher and then
we have a matcha frappe again I don't
know how this is specific to Italy
because I think the whole matcha craze
has kind of maybe spared us in a way but
there's no other place where you will
find any matcha flavoring because I
think our green thing is pistachio like
we just don't have space for two green
things to compete let's give it a try
I've never actually had it in a FR
frappucino yeah tastes like matcho just
very artificial matcho we have a bunch
of other iced coffees that you can get
here they all are and today we actually
bought the iced flat white I've had this
before and I think I really like it but
I just want to take this up again still
good still delicious it's a little milky
but it's really tasty we also have
several Iced Teas here we have the pump
cream chai the matcha lemonade a peach
green tea the London Fog iced latte an
iced passion tea the frozen strawberry
acai lemonade and the Frozen mango
dragon fruit lemonade Starbucks sells
these Evolution fresh juices this one is
orange apple mango pineapple and acerola
that sounds really good I've never had
matcha and lemonade together so let's
taste
it that's actually not bad I thought I
was going to hate it it's actually
pretty good let's try the London Fog te
tea
latte no so candly I feel like I'm going
to keep saying that why does everything
taste a little weird today I do want to
try one of these Frozen Refreshers let's
see what this strawberry acai tastes
like it's really good it tastes like
strawberry lemonade it's not frozen
anymore but it's tasty we didn't have a
bunch of smoothies we have this innocent
blue juice then the names are actually
funny cuz they there are plays play
Awards here here this one is called
fabuloso then we have a pink juice from
innocent this one has another player
word is like Rosa
aosa and if you're Italian watching this
yes I'm from the south cuz you can tell
by the way we pronounce our O's we then
have these tiny ones uh this juice is
mango passion fruit and apple and
another one with the strawberry and
banana yeah they look very nice and
natural we have other cold drinks this
one is a kinoto and they all from this
brand tomario I've actually never heard
of it but it looks like a fancy kinoto
to me so kinoto is an Italian drink made
with Bergamot we normally just have it
from s pelegrino which is like a more
commercial brand does taste good it's a
bit like the Italian version of
Coca-Cola my parents generation they
were having these not Coke we then have
a red orange um we have sparkling soda
from the same brand and and um we have
lemonade which looks very nice and then
we picked up also this uh it's just cold
infused water in Italian it's called
infuso afedo and actually we've got more
here are the rest of the cold drinks
here is the US only customizable drink
that we created this is a Cafe vanilla
coffee frap with half and half the cup
is lined with caramel sauce it's got
brown sugar syrup mocha sauce and
cinnamon dolce sprinkles and also so I
think some cookie crumbles there there
are some mysterious crumbles on top that
I have no idea where they came from
because I didn't ask for them but it
looks fun this is going to give me the
worst tummy ache I already
know that is the sweetest drink I think
I've ever tasted in my life it's too
much absolutely too much it is really
fun that Starbucks lets you customize
anything pretty much anything cuz this
would never have been made otherwise
there is a lot of food at Starbucks here
in Italy let's start from the Savory
options we've got your dear salmon
bagel I don't know is does that have
cream cheese in it no it does look like
just salmon and some herbs some like sad
salads yeah this is also cooked salmon
and aren't you big on like smoke salmon
over there I don't know Nico you are in
New York what do you think from a new
New York your point of view does that
look like a good bagel no it does not
but maybe it tastes better than it looks
then we have some toasts we have ham and
cheese looks like an Hest toast and then
we got the same version just with three
cheeses I'll be curious to know which
cheeses they are cuz they just say three
cheeses and then we've got baked fuka
with ham well okay first of all this is
not Pacha I mean I don't know what this
is it looks great actually looks very
nice and fluffy but this is not for
capture because it just doesn't have
this shape and it's too fluffy it just
looks like bread to me yeah just looks
quite nice actually like a normal
sandwich you would find it's quite
refreshing cuz I don't know when this is
going out but like the amount of burgers
and like things filled with weird sauces
I had to try for this show it's just
unbelievable and Starbucks I don't know
but like it looks like you really made
it in Italy you're like serving actually
Italian food so thank you and here we
have some of our exclusive breakfast
items this is The Impossible sandwich
the bacon and Grier egg bites the bacon
sausage egg wrap the bacon goua and egg
sandwich and here's the berry Trio
parfait let's take a bite of the
impossible sandwich I've had this before
and I feel like I mostly like it it's
just like a little bit weird if you let
it sit for too
long I feel like for a not real Sausage
Patty this actually tastes pretty good
good I've always thought that the egg
bites were like some sort of Genius move
even though Starbucks definitely didn't
invent them my favorite are the egg
white bites these don't look edible
anymore but I'll take a
bite that's really good actually I think
it's just because I got a mouthful of
bacon but it tastes really good and then
we have a bunch of
sandwiches here we call sandwiches Trini
but it's kind of translation uh we have
this one with salmon and avocado looks
nice even though the options outside of
the box look very like look delicious so
I wouldn't go for the box one uh we have
this one with a poretta which is roasted
pork from like Rome and like the Roman
region very very good and yeah if you
ever around there they also do a lot of
nice festivals so check it out uh this
one has poretta and mushrooms and the
last one is this one with linian
eggplants we also got salads we have
chicken and cheese what looks like
grated Parmesan and then we got tuna and
feta with croutons and olives again this
is all you need for a salad the only
Caesar we know here is Du Caesar I know
that's bad but actually it's true it's
just very very cliche but it's true like
we don't like sear salad and then we've
got this one it's called pincho with
cured ham uh artichoke sauce and
mozzarella okay interesting shape look
look funny I don't really know what a
pincho is it may be something from like
another Italian region I'm not so
familiar with it actually to be honest
this Artic choke is a bit of a joke cuz
there's not a lot of it
um let's try it out and
see that taste like AR actually tastes
quite natural so very nice yeah it's not
flavoring yeah I like this one we then
have some stuffed croissants because
here we're not we're not French so we're
not scared of putting things in
croissants like our friends across the
border so this they're quite similar
this one has cured ham and corta it
looks like little salad thing I honestly
I don't really like it doesn't taste
like much and it just ruins everything
visually next Grant we have I think it's
the same cheese just with cooked ham
instead in Italy we actually do eat a
lot of savory croissants uh sorry French
people um we usually eat them as like
tiny bites in like an apparative they
serve them they're like really really
this size they're very tiny we also have
this one which is supposed to be a fuka
with a plantbased
chinito I mean honestly this is not for
catcha I mean quite clearly there's been
some like mistake in the menu uh because
it's just a sandwich and I don't know
why do plant-based things always have
very sad bands like this why why don't
you use this one this looks much nicer
this is like just very sad and plain we
do have some snack SN as
well we have some mixed fruits and nuts
we have roasted and salted mix nuts and
then we have cheese snacks okay this
looks like it's um it's a thing cuz
McDonald also has those like tiny
parmesans uh those those like tiny
parmesan snacks and Starbucks seems to
be following suit and just giving you
some cheese snacks it just says it's
like a semi hard cheese and it's only
made with three ingredients nice you
know milk salt and renit okay no I'm a
bit disappointed I was expecting actual
cheese like tiny bits of cheese this is
like it's like a
chip yeah they're cheesy they're not too
bad actually moving on to our more
lunchy options this is the grilled
cheese on sourdough the tomato
mozzarella sandwich on faka they also
offer a ham and swiss on a baguette and
a turkey provolone pesto on chabata that
we did not get I want to take a bite of
this grilled cheese the bread actually
looks pretty good there's not going to
be a cheese Bowl it's it's going to
crack in half if I do that it's
literally so solid from sitting here all
day okay wait it looks like there's no
cheese even in this that's so weird it
must be like a lighter cheese I've had
way better grilled cheese but this
Bread's actually pretty tasty this
sandwich seems inspired by Italian
flavors so I'm very shocked that it's
not on the Italian menu that is one sad
looking sandwich I'm going to take a
bite from the middle don't be mad it's
just that all the filling has like moved
to the center of the
bread it's not bad it's not great but
it's not a bad sandwich it mostly tastes
like pesto we also have a variety of
protein boxes here we have the PB&J
protein box this used to be my lunch
every single day when I was in college
Starbucks in Italy has a lot of Bakery
options this I'm very excited about cuz
I think we do actually associate
Starbucks with like a Breakfast Cafe in
a way starting from a maple and peon
braid then we have a cinnamon
swirl yeah looks nice and fluffy and
then we've got the saddest saddest
looking cross ever uh this is the vegan
one it's just like a very unpleasant
Brown is this what the Lao butter makes
like just something very Brown it
doesn't feel that great and like
inside it just
actually it cuts a little bit like a
bread whoop in a
way right bread is vegan yeah so here's
some bread in the shape of a cam and
then we got another cram this one is
multigrain and honey and then we got a
plain one very good lamination actually
Starbucks look there's a lot of lot of
layers actually Starbucks called these
croissants French croissants in Italian
as well um and they actually do look
quite different uh compared to the
Italian croissants that I'm used to
Italian cants they're not made of layers
of dough and butter let's
see
a plain one I will have it only if it's
laminated this way I think the Italian
one is just really meant to be filled so
I'm curious to see how the others
actually look and feel just because they
are still the French ones but they are
filled so we got this one here with
apricot jam let's check it
out yeah lots of jam looks quite nice
and then we have the green thing here
here in Italy there is no Mata it's
pistachio tastes like a Nutty spread
quite quite a nice spread there's not a
lot of it though and final one we got
the custard this also looks quite nice
I'm just want to see how much custard
there is in here there's a lot it's a
bit eggy as well which is what I would
look for in a
custard not too lemony just a hint and
like a bit of vanilla and apparently you
can also get a Hazen the cant but we
were not able to get it um and then you
we have a double chocolate cookie and a
hazelnut
donut yeah we're starting to enter
foreign territory here maybe a bit sad
compared to what's coming after which
are these mini Donuts quite cute and
colorful and then we have some brownies
we have a caramel crumble Brownie and
then we have a triple chocolate brownie
actually quite like brownies it's uh one
of those sort of foreign cakes that uh
I'm I'm kind of very used to and I don't
mind having it let's see we do it well
here in
Italy this is like the ones I'm used to
that I've had and then we have this one
it's a raspberry and coconut loaf cake
it does look a bit like a typical
Italian cake we I have no idea that this
type of cakes we called loaf cakes but
seems quite accurate not quite convinced
about the stuff on the top it just
doesn't seem necessary I would have put
it inside just to flavor the dough
rather than just put it at the top and
then we have a strawberry cheesecake
then you may also be able to find apple
pie apricot field Rings custard and
raisin swir then a vanilla chocolate
muffin that's also available in triple
chocolate brownie and orange mini
chocolate muffins carrot cake that can
also be red velvet and chocolate cake
and a milk chocolate gold coin the US
also has a lot of baked goods we have a
couple of the iconic Starbucks cake pops
I want to take a bite of this cookies
and green
one that's so good this is the Blueberry
Scone the everything bagel the petite
vanilla scone the coffee cake even
though it looks like someone sat on it
it looks a little smooshed but it's very
good the incredible incomparable lemon
loaf it's delicious the glazed dut I did
say that Italy's Bagel didn't look that
good not that ours looks any better but
I just want to taste the everything
bagel to see what the flavor is
giving it's like mediocre it's not that
good on flavor and it's not a great
texture
I would only reach for a Starbucks Bagel
if I was like going on a flight or
something and this was just like my only
option I don't think that I would ever
purchase it with a million other good
bagel options around me so the pumpkin
loaf and the pumpkin cream cheese muffin
our seasonal exclusives along with the
baked apple croissant which was not
available today I feel like people are
buying them like crazy they're really
good and if you want the little snacks
there are also these options we got
yogurt with Wild Flour honey and yogurt
with berries and jam then we got some
fruits you can also get pineapple and
then we've got just a fruit salad and
finally we've got this thing the cookie
stroll so is this how you're supposed to
have it this feels like something a
child will have it's like I'm alone at
home and I'm like 12 I'm having a very
calorific drink with like weird
stro yeah
weird actually don't mind the strw per
se but just the idea seems so
ridiculous we also got a few iconic
Starbucks checkout snacks so this is the
marshmallow dream bar we have the melins
and we also have the vanilla almond
biscotti I see these at every single
Starbucks I go to and I'm always tempted
to buy one I kind of want to try these
melins I don't think I've ever had a
meline
before that's pretty good it kind of
tastes like a cakey sugar cookie I don't
know if it's supposed to taste like that
but it does taste like that you may also
know Starbucks for the Starbucks Reserve
roasteries that are very much present in
the US you can also find them in other
countries and actually there's one here
in Italy too in Milan that open in 2018
and the roasteries are famous for having
different types of coffee that have the
rarest coffee that you can find at
Starbucks they offer experiences at
these roasteries where they demonstrate
different ways to make the coffee
through blending brewing and infusions
and they also have wine beers cocktails
some of which include coffee they have a
lot of food options too each Roastery is
a little different in its architecture
so it's really interesting just to have
a look around unfortunately we were not
able to visit The Roastery in this trip
but we actually went in 2018 so we're
going to play some footage of our visit
I was there we took a visit to one of
the roasteries here in New York City it
was really cool to see how they make
these different drinks and everything in
there is so fancy compared to a regular
Starbucks these are the drinks exclusive
to the New York Roastery that we wanted
to try let's start with the hazelnut
Bianco latte I love hazelnut
so it's really good it's really really
really good I feel like it tastes better
than any other Starbucks Coffee I've had
let's try the whiskey barrel-aged cold
brew this is intriguing to me I hate
whiskey but there's no real whiskey in
this
okay wait it tastes like there is
whiskey in it but there isn't I made
sure to say like alcohol-free what I I
think from what I'm understanding is
that they might age this in the whiskey
barrels once the whiskey is removed from
those barrels but it still tastes very
strong whiskey barrel it's spiritfree
but the spirits are lurking you can
still taste it this was actually
actually invented in Italy and then yeah
launched again recreated at The Roastery
uh this is the oato CAF latte and oato
just literally means oil and it's just a
CAF latte with short of olive oil
apparently um this is the CEO of
Starbucks that traveled to Italy to
Sicily and just saw some people having
shots of olive oil and coffee and
thought it would be a good idea to roll
this out internationally and for some
reason thought that all Italians were
actually doing it I don't know it's the
first time I hear it like I will be
quite happy to have a shot of olive oil
for Just Energy but I don't know if I
would like it in my coffee that seems
like a bit too much it's like oh what
are two things Italians are associated
with olive oil and coffee let's just put
them all together and make it a drink
it's
green it's green and I like the oil is
floating on the coffee Al so the idea is
that they should emulsify but you know
it's been sitting here for a bit cuz
we've been doing all the filming so
perhaps that's why they separated it
just smells like coffee let's try it
out I don't taste much the olive oil
which is okay it leaves you a different
feeling on the lips like the same
feeling that you get when you like bite
into a very oily thing this is the
moment that I've been dreading this
entire day the oato cafe lattes these
are basically lattes with a bunch of
olive oil in them I don't know whose
idea this was it doesn't sound like a
good idea to me but let's see which one
is better iced or not
iced it's not bad I can definitely taste
that there's oil in this but it's not
like aggressively oily in my mouth which
is what I was really dreading it's
really not terrible I think it's the oat
milk that's helping cover up up some of
what's happening this looks terrible the
iced latte has completely like separated
so the top is just a layer of olive oil
which means I'm going to get a mouthful
of olive oil upon first
sip it just tastes like a mouthful of
olive oil let me mix it with a straw and
see if that helps to be clear this
didn't look like this when they first
gave it to us it's just been sitting
around for a while it tastes better but
still mostly tast tastes like olive oil
I think if I had to get an oato again I
would only get it hot just because it
covers up all the olive oil flavor which
kind of defeats the purpose of getting
one of these but they're not
terrible it's quite hard actually for me
to think that Starbucks is actually
competing with the cafes that you can
find here just because the offer is very
very different like it's the only place
where you can find drinks this size this
elaborate and with this this much cream
and like milk and syrups and all this
stuff I would say in general Starbucks
is definitely huge here you can find
them everywhere I feel like you're
either a Duncan person or you're a
Starbucks person and it's very common
for a chain like Starbucks to be
somebody's everyday coffee shop I will
say if you live in a major city with a
lot of other options a lot of different
coffee shops you might not head to
Starbucks all the time but it is one of
the more popular coffee options in
places like suburbs it's hard to say
that's popular cuz it is not really
present everywhere uh obviously it is in
Milan Rome and like the big cities but
you won't find it in a village what we
do I'm from like a mediumsized town in
Italy but in the evening I'll go out to
a small town you know during the day
I'll go out for a day trip in a small
town I won't live there but I will hang
around there that's where you don't find
the chains and I think that is what you
know still makes Starbucks perceived as
something a bit foreign because you
still don't see it in the tiny towns and
you still see the local cafe like it's
just in general the idea of change
doesn't really resonate well in terms of
the actual coffees like the long coffees
I don't know actually if they get lot of
orders from like Italians I think you
either just I would either go
personally just for simple espresso or
from the elaborate like for the
elaborate things because they are bit
like an ice cream to me treat yourself
but also like if I see you drinking that
cookie crumble mocha frap at 9:00 in the
morning I'm going to slap it out of your
hand grow up please just the culture of
like the big drink to take away to like
drink on the go drink in your car that's
just no that's just not how things work
around here people really love the
Starbucks seasonal menus I think every
year when fall or Christmas time rolls
around everyone gets super excited to
see what new stuff is on the menu what
old stuff is coming back I mean speaking
of the food I think they've done a very
good job sort of adapting to the Italian
you know flavors um the drinks are a
little bit different U there are some
things like cookies and cream that are
just not Italian we all know that
Starbucks is a big American chain and I
think they obviously want to keep a part
of that uh because you know Italians are
curious about it as
well unfortunately Starbucks does not
list uh ingredients on it website we did
try to get in contact but we're still
waiting for a reply the US however does
provide all of the ingredients for their
full menu we thought it would be
interesting to see what's in the oato
range since both us and Italy have this
available the oato cafe latte with oat
milk contains oat milk which is just
water and oats canola oil di potassium
phosphate calcium carbonate Tri calcium
phosphate sea salt dicalcium phosphate
riboflavin vitamin A vitamin Vin D2
vitamin B12 brw espresso which is just
watering coffee and extra virgin olive
oil the exciting thing about this drink
is the addition of extra virgin olive
oil which is mostly associated with a
Mediterranean diet it does ramp up the
calories compared to a normal lat which
with 2% milk is 190 calories but there's
been a lot of research surrounding the
benefits of extra virgin olive oil
particularly around preventing diseases
and decreasing cholesterol plus the oato
latte has been fortified with vit so
sounds pretty good to me even though I'd
never order this
again in the US aventi caramel
frappuccino is
$6.75 or
€37 keep in mind that's a New York price
the prices might vary slightly depending
on what state you're in in Italy a
caramel frappuccino is
570 that translates to roughly
$619 so it actually works out cheaper
here in Italy in the US a venti
cappuccino is
$66.25 or €
5.90 in Italy a venti capucino
is340 in dollars that translates into
$369 to be honest they're kind of fair
judging by how big the things are coffee
is always quite cheap actually in Italy
um it's usually around € lately has gone
up a little bit but like if you pay 150
it's already very expensive make note of
the fun Colonel Sanders doing a
cartwheel wasn't this a guy like 70 when
he started Kentucky Fried Chicken so no
way he's doing if he's doing that it's
against his
will moments before the ambulance was
called